thank you
[Music]
I'll see you in the chat I see y'all
already might check might check I want
to make sure my levels are good around
talk to me right quick let me know if
y'all can hear me okay I see Lydia
master in there I see Pop Lock two in
there brewski boy all right IOP lfg Okay
g g Park okay guy what's wrong okay
Galveston said do I sound good
could you give a mic check to the people
right quick ten nine eight seven six
five that's professional you get that
that's that Washington Post right there
boy professionals let's go yeah he good
y'all heard Gene okay what's up live
Supremacy all right cool cool cool no
doubt I appreciate it y'all um we doing
I just doing a new setup right now so
Lord Alex helped me set something up for
the first time so we're trying to get
the stream better on the back end so
that's why we doing all this but we got
the legendary Gene Park in the building
we will talk to y'all in a minute Lord
King Lord saw everybody's waking up and
pulling up so uh we're gonna talk yeah
but we have a good show today man have
some fun and let me tell me to fix my
face I honestly
you fix your face
let's do Jersey what up I see you so
look we will be back we got the
legendary uh Gene Park in the building
yeah I'm hyped too we're gonna have some
fun we're gonna talk some games I'm
excited so anyway see y'all in a bit
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them rain uses a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back leave
with messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my TV but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
um
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and Snapple and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
AIM check my vocals follow on Twitter
but I'm anti-social or my city but I'm
still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all too
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and sampling making
it flammable this is that this is that
Yoga Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up
in the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back we was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look You Oughta messed up and
turned me to an animal and headers be
swearing ain't real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
I'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being a cannibal and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beating they
want to compare me to Freddie and Jason
I'd rather be Hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all too Dramatical I know it's random
but I'm addicted to flipping and Sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is the Yoga Fire Flame they think
it's Arsen up in the apartment they call
a department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
um
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be Neato
I know it's my destiny work to carnido
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't nothing but
really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke King
David still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful
we'll let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord day
[Music]
now what we're going to do is I see
levels I just need a little by check
from anybody real quick
hola hola hola hola yes sir yes sir yes
sir my check my check uh sitting in the
building that's what's up I think we are
good and here you hear you we are live
welcome to the iron Lord podcast LLC and
also live on lordsofgaming.net episode
number 287. it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's day I'm extremely excited about
our special guest and we've got the Xbox
developer direct Last of Us HBO series
and ubisoft's future to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord whose
credentials dedication to his craft and
deep respect within the ranks of
professional journalism are truly a
sight to behold not only does this lord
always exude a pure passion for the art
of video games but is also an honest
defender of the culture exuding
unparalleled strength as one of our
absolute favorite survivors
introducing the Washington Post games
reporter and the host of the G Park
YouTube channel
the Lord of action adventure fgc
Community a jrpgs whose love for Tribe
Called Quest in 3-6 Mafia easily
certifies him as official of these
hip-hop streets live from DC and the
pride of Cal State Fullerton who is kind
enough to make his debut into the realm
of the Lord my man Lord Gene Park of the
Washington Post how are we doing sir
my least good to be here in the world in
the realm of the Lords uh it's it's
amazing it makes amazing to be here and
and an honor to to receive one of those
legendary intros that you always give
like um like like I've been watching you
get you guys show and I'm like man every
intro just like knocks it out the park
amazing thank you brother okay just out
of curiosity how'd you come across oh
you want to know all right that's
delicious questions all right but he
want to know that I got Attica he want
to know how you first came across them
or when did you first come across the
look it was actually through you Lord
Clark uh through through defining Duke
you know I knew Mandy before that and I
was like you know like Lord God's got to
come from somewhere too and I looked it
up and I was like okay okay okay there
you go that's what's up man what you
appreciated man shout out to Mr Madden
please you already know what it is so
first of all how you feeling brother and
what have you been playing
good good I've been feeling good you
know uh uh as as many of you know I I
just got through beating cancer uh
crazy stuff right uh absolutely
hopefully it stays that way uh so uh
yeah I've just been trying to get used
to feeling good again you know uh I'm
I'm playing playing a lot of games uh
it's interesting you catching me at an
interesting time I'm playing a game
that's embargoed right now
I don't think I can I could talk about
it quite yet
I'm just afraid you can tell you could
break in yeah just ruin your career man
look he the man just beat cancer you
tried to get him to quit his job
[Laughter]
if that happens he won't be quitting his
job
okay dude okay
I watched last week
I've been playing the Darksiders Trilogy
remember that
like I like yeah because what's your
favorite
uh I I you know you know what two is
better but I have a soft spot for one
yes yeah I do too I like War yeah War I
like I like War like like I like the
characters you know like you got the
Joker up in the mix up there yeah camel
um
and it just it's just those are just
nice simple games they remind me of like
Legacy okay and Soul Reaver yeah
open world puzzle games you know yeah so
it's kind of kind of Zelda like
especially that first one yeah very very
very very very Zelda like so you know we
haven't got a good job in like in a good
while so I was like okay well you know I
can do some Darksiders hopefully we get
one this year yeah exactly that'd be
nice just just don't just don't put
Starfield right next to it
stop running from stuff
you know what's funny man they were so
money bars from that star filter thing
that was like half the clip yeah the
cliff was crazy last week with the
Starfield section it was absolutely but
anyway so it's been just that oh geez uh
I've been playing River City girls too
you know me I'm a huge I'm huge into fgc
but you know like as part of the fgc you
usually get our into also Brawlers too
yes yes and Brawlers are a part of the
are are kind of like part of that
lineage too
for me for me River City Ransom is like
one of the first games I played back in
back in the NES days yeah I was like it
was like it was like Grand Theft Auto 3
for me back in the day so you can just
walk walk around like punch dudes yeah
and like eat and like take a bath and
like like do all kinds of stuff like
that's crazy I was like like this is the
metaverse right here bro
the fact that we're still getting like
River City girls games like real City
games that you can you can still do that
you can still walk around and beat up
dudes and like like go to shops and
stuff like that and level up like that's
so it's so addictive so I'm wedgie bro
we come from that era we come from that
era I mean assist with solved with the
Double Dragons and the yeah
little beater bumps man that's what it
was absolutely I love that love that
love the choices there you already know
and we got the uh Four Horsemen of
gaming those original Lords of the realm
at the round table kind of abbreviated
intros because we want to get as much in
we got a big show today
you know you better give it give me your
time
we gotta go quick and then he takes
daytime it's always addict and you know
solved yeah you know me I'm such a
talker
because the guy I am I'll step on that
grenade it's me it's always
speaking of GSU my co-host with the
combos my brother for another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf
mommy Lord addict of the attic show
fresh off that punch out
oh Millennials playing punch out how he
went
uh it was I I want to say out of all the
wack stuff you guys be making me play uh
that that was definitely probably the
funnest thing I put out fire right I
actually enjoy doing that nice you know
um
I definitely could beat that game if I
put more time into it and learn more of
the the patterns because if you really
like break it down after I fought them
it only took me probably about 20 30
minutes to learn their patterns it's
it's pretty much just playing like a
Dark Souls game you have to learn yeah
the final way to go through the little
holes I was just like the d-pad it's
hard for me to use because I didn't come
from that era and like sometimes I'll
try to go like left or right but I go
straight and go left right go straight I
diagonals was a little shaky back then
listen it was a fun time how about after
this you you played the original punch
out
that isn't that the original Poncho no
oh you talk about the big boys
with the greens with the green
Silhouettes
but the one you played yeah you're fine
man you're fine Nintendo took the a nice
formula and it was good yeah yeah they
definitely made it better because the
other one is horrible the last one I
played the last dude I beat on there I
think was um the ball dude
but I heard I heard King Hippo was was
outside yeah in the beginning you know I
called that I called King Hippo
people when he was moving I noticed he
had like a little bandage on his stomach
so I kind of figured that's what was
going on on and everyone else this big
dude you know strength they sitting
there flexing and this dude come out
there look looking like he he a villain
off of something so you know it's so
clearly they wanted you to to look at
his gut like that so I was like but at
first I thought you had a like just hit
him and there's like no you have to hit
him with his mouth open I'm like and
then see they tried they trick you
because his regular attacks
the attacks that he regularly does and
the ones he do with his mouth open are
literally scripted the exact same way so
you have to wait but what I what I
noticed is like when you hit him and he
doesn't like do it with his mouth open
like he just stops the attack he doesn't
like actually attack you so yeah it was
it was the the black dude what's that
dude's name key that's the dude that
gave me more issues
I got to the point where I could beat
him pretty easy like he he had well when
he was doing like the side swipe like
literally you just hit that side you get
those Stars those Stars I was obsessed
with them
it was done flamaco yeah
because at first he didn't know how to
dodge
it's not that it's like he would kind of
like I noticed like when he came off of
a round or a knockout he would
immediately try to hit you once and he
wouldn't do the hit me hit me like that
so it was a fun time it was a fun stuff
I appreciate it I told you I don't take
long
and then talk about some some
PlayStation Fanboy that's on Twitter and
then do a big talk anyway so that's been
it and other than that which what have
you been playing sir
um
that that was about all I've been
playing a lot of chained Echo
all right I've been playing fortnite too
okay okay I mean that at that at this
point that's just a given like I've been
playing fortnite like every week you
know it just I I really enjoy it I I
enjoy the way that I used to think Call
of Duty is the most influential game in
history no fortnite beats Call of Duty
by mile because it's just it's crazy how
mainstream they've made everything you
want to go in there playing as uh is
Deku for my hair we got you Goku we got
you the Darth Vader we got you there's
no other game in history you could think
that you could go in there they have
people making commercials with different
characters like it's just insane yeah
the pop culture is crazy
absolute salute and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also that's
ostradamus the Lord of clarity and Lord
patreon of the iron bake my man Lord
solvent how we doing sir I am good doing
fantastic I uh didn't have much time for
gaming this week I did a uh just you
know a little bit of vampire survivors
but not much beyond that I want to give
addict a shout out though you know why
because I love it when like uh somebody
comes to a game like a game they've
never played before this game is like 35
years old and you you have that first
experience because it's nothing like
that first experience no matter how old
the game is yeah that's another thing
people in the chat was like cloudy on me
and I was like dude you played this like
for five years straight never beat it
but it but it is like it is all in good
fun because again
35 even when we were sitting there as
young kids playing that game the first
time we're getting smoked by glass junk
and smoke Von Kaiser and it's like is
this thing of like to see somebody going
through that for the first time all
these years later it's so much fun
because listen I try to do that I try to
guinea pig my nephew all the time hey
try this game like because they don't
care about it no they don't I'm like try
this game is awesome he's like not
fortnite
yeah I know so you know it's fun when
somebody does that uh because again it's
a new experience to them and it's and
it's like being back there again in that
moment yes yeah it didn't recognize the
greatness of the game right yeah exactly
that's the game that holds up like
addict said some of the other stuff that
was played yeah some of the stuff that
he's playing you know even Ninja Gaiden
and stuff like that that stuff is has an
age as well you know I like Ninja Gaiden
that was an okay game yeah um I I really
enjoyed uh punch out but I the the one
by far I didn't like was Shinobi I just
I would I would have had you play ninja
scroll or Turbo Graphics instead oh
ninja ninja Spirits yeah yeah that's a
tough game
well last night I got to extend the
birthday festivities once again
you know how Puerto Ricans do yeah we
sell them we sell eight eight days at a
time
[Laughter]
all celebration since at least eight
days right so
um yeah so I went out with Lord
marlonius oh salute shout out to Marley
uh yeah we went uh we were in Jersey we
had some fantastic Cuban food that was
amazing yes sir yes sir and then we went
to um a place like I guess New Jersey
guys would know about is called
retrocades yes
retro caves is awesome because it is
like a classic it's like a big in the
family environment it's a huge arcade uh
sort of space where you have a bunch of
old school games you have pinball games
you have pool tables I mean they had it
they had a pong uh Whatchamacallit wow
sort of uh what do they call it the uh I
forget what they call it it's a huge
pong table
um you know pool tables they have a
space for like birthday parties air
hockey and then they also have multiple
television setups with different
consoles on each like retro consoles on
each so you could be playing playing PS5
uh and Xbox series X on one the other
the one right next to it'll be like an
N64 and a PS1 and you could just pick
between them and sit on the couch and
play all these old school games and fine
and going there with Marlon is fun
because Marlin again has he fell off
pretty much at the PS3 generate huge gap
so he's seen some of these games he's
like they were playing um new Super
Mario Brothers you or something on the
the the the remaster or the re-release
for the switch yeah and he's like what
game is that I'm like that's on the
switch dude like that and he's looking
at like an awe like I can't even see so
and that's another thing when I see
Marlon play games I enjoy that because
uh you know again he's he's so far
behind it it's all brand new he's brand
new to him
it was so much fun but we will we're
getting a retro on yesterday it was fun
that we're talking about those beat em
ups because we were playing uh we played
Captain America and the Avengers we
played X-Men they had the X-Men six
player cabinet there a lot of a lot of
the the sticks were busted or whatever
but it was still fun to play they had
turtles in time obviously they had all
this other stuff Alien versus Predator
School NBA Jam yeah
oh my God I forgot how good that
freaking thing is so good oh man what
they didn't have was final fight and
they didn't have the Punisher with the
punishers Oh The Punisher oh
so what I got a little bit more you talk
about the one from Capcom or the one
from Sega
no Sega did the the 3D one that was uh
on the Xbox right and Playstation Two
yeah no this was the arcade one the
arcade one and that was that was fun too
as well yeah they didn't have that but
um it was just a fun time I got to play
a little bit of Tekken RK
I still had it really dead cradles
wow
it's like it's muscle memory man I give
you credit I'm mad as hell
yeah
gee like saw was a beast with the
character King in Tekken and he'll get
you in those wrestling locks and those
links and you'll just watching
playing against a master King player you
just see your energy ball Whittle down
and you can't escape I remember that one
time that I'm fighting him and then I'm
managed to get out and he got me in
right back
he grabbed me did it again oh man the
hell with this dude
this is only one part that you can
escape from if you missed that window
you're done yeah yeah those are the time
of the Lakes but that's what is it that
was it bad shout out to Molly it was a
great extended birthday uh celebration
you don't know and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gamer the prophet of Xbox
Swami King of the statues the Bears
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
fantastic no combat talk yesterday had a
good day uh did the Lord's minute uh
that was fun so look out for that on the
Lord's gaming.net where we have a ton of
good stuff up there yeah
I
am good oh no no nothing um this week
I've been playing Sonic uh shout out to
everborn calling me on that Monday with
the the I heard you was talking greasy
about Sonic talk oh yeah he the Sonic
police
too yeah well I gave him my Arguments
for for why it was the wackiest most
boring disjointed uh Frankenstein of a
Sonic that I've ever seen
come at you you got a nice review
I'm gonna tell you why and it's very
simple Sonic is not drab and boring and
that Overworld is just that the sound
they could have they could have I know
it's a dystopian world but um that it
just felt so disconnected and then when
you have the going in the the it's like
the Sonic Adventure levels those are
really tight but it feels like when they
took uh Zack Snyder's Justice League and
gave Josh weed in it and it was the uh
Frankenstein of a movie this feels like
a Frankenstein of a game like it was two
different ideas going on with the game
and it disconnects the player from the
game because all you want to do is get
to the Sonic levels where you bursting
around and you want to avoid the Hub
world but you can't avoid the Hub world
because that's where you get your powers
and that's where they're trying to take
Sonic so it just felt so disjointed but
I've seen on that Sonic game is it feels
like that's the right direction just do
something different with that Foundation
poorly executed right direction poorly
actually I'll let you get his balls off
he got a great article about it gee do
you have any encounters to this Sonic
slander no I actually I actually have to
agree uh you know like the music and the
Sonic the adventure stages are are W you
know like they're absolutely amazing you
know like it's just all dance tracks
it's amazing because you can play it in
the club and the people won't even
notice right yeah
um but the music in the Overworld like
he said it's it's kind of an L because
like like the energy just leaves you you
know like you don't feel it anymore and
it's not like so it's supposed to be fun
so yeah it's it's it's it's a little
weird but you know like for me like I
like I just like running around in Sonic
in an open world like like yeah I don't
even have to do anything so that's just
fun for me
Sonic fans like like the the bar is
lower for us
you're willing to accept it
there's a lot with jokes
that was funny I'm sorry okay so
um just playing that uh downloaded a
couple of games on game pass but uh
Fortnight mainly and it's between monkey
and attic attitude got to this thing now
what you make sure that he calls me at
nine o'clock no matter what it is
and I know exactly it's going to be him
because soon as I pull up into Hollis
Queens yeah my phone goes off I'm like
because he know I'm pulling into
holidays and we're talking from there
and he's because you have a schedule and
that's when you go there it's at 9 30
every morning there you go but it's like
he's securing the bag yes yes so what
you doing today what's going on what's
going on just putting in my bed we're
going on fortnite how long is it gonna
take you to get home
so as soon as I get in it's either him
and then right after this monkey so
something like Fortnight out right there
I've like I've like picked up a lot of
like personal stuff going on like I
helped like my mom get back and forth
and stuff I'm like during that time is
where I don't have to do nothing
day they don't have to do nothing no
doubt so it's been pretty much it king
that's it waiting for these fights to
happen and you know this R and all with
the Lords we having a good time salute
salute and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the Shinobi Lord Cognito
spreading that realness and Roman IOP
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear shout out to Mr
Maddie play Shout out to find dude had a
good one talking about the developer
direct the announcement all that good
stuff you know what I mean shout out to
my man e bontin shout out to Thai Guy
Travis the last word talking that
Destiny talks these are the Seraph and a
lot of quality of life changes that
Bungie's making prior to life for to
make it accessible to players salute to
them I thought that was really cool um
for me game wise um I've been playing
obviously that's the season sir from
doing a revision zero Quest and then I
restarted uh Crisis Core because I was
like you know what I gotta I was playing
Midnight Sun so much that I'm like I
started I forgot what I was doing let me
just start over so I just started I
don't know how I feel about Zach voicing
I I'm still I'm a little bothered by it
but he he's winning me over he's just
such a good person he's like he sounds
like Sonic the Hedgehog
yeah
the thing about him as if uh you better
get used to that voice because I have a
feeling he's gonna have a huge role in
these new uh yeah the way the way the
rebate is going we let's see how this
thing go go but uh yeah I've been
rocking out that but uh other than that
she's got to pay the bills but I know we
got Jesus we gotta um yeah slow-mo
Zach's voice is awful yeah I am not
feeling his voice he's just a little too
too yeah like Sonic a little bit but
anyway yeah so um yeah I've got some
updates real quick so um shout out to
our good Lords in the EU you guys have
been very patient valari time man gonna
get you a gaming pillows we gotta we
gotta get your Volaris going you guys
have been very patient because you want
to get together in Mine mine's on the
bed get your gaming pot to prevent that
game of lean y'all you know what I mean
you put that thing right around the West
put your controller down with those long
gaming sessions and this way you don't
stress your brother so look U.S guys
we're good but um actually for our EU
and UK you guys have been asking they
are now available for pre-order so go to
this site it is up in the
here we go so I'm gonna put this in the
chat right now the link again use code
Lord 15 get your 15 off of the velari
gaming pillow and again for my EU and UK
brothers please put them in now do not
wait because stock is a little bit more
limited over there as opposed to our us
brothers so just I know everybody you
guys have been saying yeah okay we we
you guys really been coming through with
these pillows man we almost there man we
almost there yeah it was UK people man
that you guys said you wanted somewhere
we made it happen we made it happen but
again put your pre-order in and then for
everybody for everyone in the US UK EU
mid to end end of March is when our
shipping is that's when you guys will
get your exclusive ILP valari pillow
with the embroidery with the black and
gold all that good stuff so go check
that out so uh akw so the CMA approved
they're selling of the pillow yo you
stupid
I just didn't but look so you heard it
here first go get your joints it's up
there so we got that also one or two
times yes oh no we're selling that pound
I'm gonna get to the pound of CW I gotta
try it okay before we get to the powder
you know what I'm saying the other
business though first was salute to my
brother hog law
um reasonable Minds can rebuild our
brother is fighting back obviously for
those who didn't know you know what I'm
saying he had a stroke and um he
underwent brain surgery
um they got the alleviated the pressure
he's out of the ICU breathed on his own
eyes open he's fighting back y'all and
now he's in rehab so obviously with all
the logistics of good rehab facilities
you know a brother needs some help so
shout out to the family they have a
GoFundMe out shout out to the community
the community came through so what I
want to do is I still want to put this
information out there you know I mean
right there this is for for Hogue law
our brother go check that out if you
want to support our brother while he
goes through the rehab situation shout
out to Mr folklore shout out to the
entire hog law family you know what I
mean he's he's really out there and we
want our brother to recover we expect
him hopefully to make a full recovery so
if you want to support you want to do
something for the family the Link's in
the description go check that out and
then last but not least yeah Advanced GG
y'all you're saying I got the powder you
know what I mean we doing we doing we do
we got the new line you know what I'm
saying we got the Spartacus blood y'all
go get that Spartacus blood we got the
focus the Spartacus what tiger blood we
got the Spartacus tiger okay because I
could have sworn it was an animal
involved yeah yeah it's Tigers it's
tight because it's wild tigers evolved
with the Spartacus you know what I'm
saying get that so you wanna you don't
get your longer gaming sessions and
again if you don't want that you just do
a little energy at the gym we got you
know what I'm saying them cans y'all we
got them Advanced GG kids go check that
out
I'm not sending it to that person with
that voice
that person would definitely can't get
no kids that's come pre-mixed this is
the premix yeah for the guys that don't
want it that time to put the water and
mix it up and all that which is me yeah
it you go get the kids you go get that
but the new news since we promote health
is wealth you know what I'm saying we're
doing it right we got them gummies y'all
we got the we got yeah kick this for you
I got you bro we got our multivitamins
you know what I'm saying get your
multivitamin on a gift for guys like me
we owe so we need that turmeric you know
what I'm saying for the inflammation you
know what I'm saying get your turmeric
on and then of course you know you know
you hit the gym a lot you do it a lot
you know them joints be aching man get
the joint support man go do that
I think I gotta give to your house yeah
bro I got you don't say Advanced GG the
clicks description I'm gonna put that
back up for y'all right now I get 30 off
this week this weekend till Monday so 30
off use iron Lord Thirty I'm just gonna
put that back up in the chat for y'all
it's pretty to the top but I'm gonna put
it in there one more time so you guys go
support the advanced GG movement yo
sliver he said Cog pushing all these
products
listen man we doing that thing out here
let me copy this right here and go check
the yes take the gummies there you go
there you go so Links at the top and in
the description go check that out and
it's up now but that is all I got as far
as the business so we good and uh James
been patient
um now that we got to what I'm sorry
you want me to get these yes please
please super chats I forgot I'm sorry
okay cool let's do that and that way I'm
just from behind so we got Matt without
fear remember for one 12 months Lord
silver great to see Lord Gene in the
realm and in good health just celebrated
my IOP membership anniversary happy to
help support my favorite gaming podcast
appreciate you and we have Matt hot
right remember for one year twenty
dollars with that nothing special to say
just happy to be here on the Lord's day
with the Lords and the legend Gene Park
yokago you already know Glock 30 let's
go early
and we have let's put the crest in the
chat for God's Soul it was meant but
around Lord love that name I like that
little
we have a heartbeat Cinema but for one
year ten dollars per chat watching attic
play Punch Out made me pick up my switch
and play while watching attic
with only one match lost to bald bull
the memories from that game so good yeah
that game holds up man that game really
holds up Justin Honda was working at it
yeah
yeah he was he was smoking at it for a
little bit it don't matter he still went
down
then we have free R Kelly oh man he back
twenty dollars Super Chat been gone
since Sony neutered god of war and
Callisto protocol flopped Last of Us
show getting 10 out of 10 reviews from
journalists is a red flag
what I'm expecting Neil gruckman to mess
it up
but keep in mind you know everyone in
the chat you know me and King will be
talking about The Last of Us episode one
this Tuesday on r r at uh 5 p.m so yes
sir definitely go into that no doubt
yeah
NBA we haven't seen it yet
I tried through back channels how did
that happen
I'm on the acquisition of how you got
the stuff continue
he said he tried I wasn't successful you
know moving on then we have Phase 23
Beacon what twenty dollars in the chat
with the Activision blizzard deal
doesn't go through Twitter is going to
be hell for Xbox fans that day
for the next year
that don't go through y'all gonna have a
parade
continue then we have a log out of
Twitter that day like on the real it'll
be messy it'll be messy then we have
Malcolm W5 Super Chat what do you guys
think Hogwarts Legacy is going to do
first week and where do you think future
of that franchise is headed stay blessed
hardworks Legacy is going to kill I
think it's going to do very well
everyone is the top selling it's crazy
yeah
you you got like a little bit of like a
canceling thing going on there but what
I've noticed like the people that don't
support the cancer culture stuff like
that will support it even if they had no
intentions on buying it just because
oh yeah speaking of that thing uh shout
out to you and and Cog and Maddie for uh
uh right before the holidays there was
somebody wrote in talking about my mini
Ranch about Hogwarts Legacy and you guys
had a discussion about it and I guess in
the most recent episode also uh you guys
talked about it again uh Maddie had a
mini rant on it as well
we will be playing that game day one yes
I had to hold you down thank you
moving on Steam Sir okay I mean I just
need to know because I know one got a
special dungeon oh you're talking about
exclusive content yeah that's what I'm
talking about you know yo pay to play
yeah
uh let me see that we have one more we
have um what you're going to say is
Malcolm W says we missed his Super Chat
no I just that's the one I just read
didn't I okay just want to make sure
that's the that's the Hogwarts one okay
you have another one no I don't know
Malcolm Malcolm just make sure we got
you because I saw it at 1 30 he said we
missed his super chat but okay just make
sure we had him let's go let's go down
hold on a second shout out to Buddha
time what up Buddha we have Brick House
Arch seven dollar Super Chat love the
health this wealth Mantra and earning
the right to game at the gym right now
listening to my favorite podcast
yeah I went to the gym like five days
last week and literally could not go
yesterday before I I can't I can't move
my arm because that's good
make sure you're getting that Advantage
GG in there get the multi-bottom bruh he
got to be out there right don't hurt the
joints man don't use cold iron Lord 30
tell you 30 this week bro anyway that's
right yeah we got the angry therapist MD
can't stay just stopping by showing love
and King addict remember it's official
Master cheeks oh man that's an RNR John
then we have Matt without fear once
again two pounds to protect just
pre-ordered my ILP bellary pillow hey he
used cold
that's right beautiful beautiful thank
you appreciate that appreciate it
Hollywood rules five dollars to protect
good afternoon my NYC video game cousins
Cog I see your 49ers King heard you on
with boom yesterday have a great pot as
always best video game podcast thank you
sir gang early early I know what it is
y'all know what it is oh God
then we have THX 1138 two dollars of a
chat PS fans watching movies Xbox fans
playing games oh no here we go
I don't know if you know but we've been
accused of being a you know an Xbox I
don't know why I don't know could it be
the green that I'm wearing right now
they
absolutely do not
yeah so brick house uh let me know was
it Brick House oh man said he's good he
said yeah we read his connection was
slow and oh he didn't realize okay he
said he back so we all caught up with
all that good stuff yes sir all right
thank you now we got playing the
business is out the way Jesus been
patient we have to switch our Focus to
Lord G his video game system history his
journey into journalism and of course
what led him to becoming a games
reporter for one of the most prestigious
outlets in newspapers The Washington
Post so Lord G let's start from the very
beginning what some of the first video
game systems you had and what got you
into gaming
what got me into gaming I was at a
friend's house and he played the Jordan
meckler game karotica
and that was the first time I saw I saw
a video game and I was like I need to
get into this yeah like as soon as I
went home I kept begging my parents I
was like this video game thing I like I
need it you know crazy like like you got
like Sticky Fingers like punching each
other that's crazy so I got into games
on the ground floor I'm 41 years old
like I I had an Atari 2600 you know
there we go go I was playing you know
yar's Revenge let's go if y'all remember
that you know yeah
yeah I even had the old school Pac-Man
the infamous Pac-Man Port
yeah
that's what we learned there was a
difference between the arcade and the
home but we had it though that is
exactly what we learned that there was a
difference
yeah Gene when you got the when you got
the uh the art box the art box was
exciting and you put it in it was like
oh what the hell I saw actually yet
yesterday at yestercades I saw the the
cartridge they have it because they have
stuff for sale as well but it's
exorbitantly priced I just remember
looking at that cover like oh wow you
look cartoonish almost like the Saturday
morning cartoons like oh wow Pac-Man you
throw it on
Pac-Man
yeah it looks as good as like the Adam
Sandler like movie like yeah
yeah
so you had to have it you had the 2600
so they they they acquiesced and they
got you to 26. yeah yeah my grandma my
grandmother blessed her heart uh she she
got me a Nintendo you know and like like
a grip of games like 30 games
oh she pulled up those games cost a lot
of money yeah yeah yeah you know like oh
grandma was
richer the kage
oh yes okay River City Ransom we were
talking about earlier yes uh Double
Dragon of course
you know at all the Nintendo games for
Castlevania all that stuff that was so
good man yeah so my console history you
know I was a Nintendo boy you know I
even I even have the issue of the
Nintendo fan club magazine just remember
the last the last issue before became
Nintendo Power I was a subscriber for
that and then I was I was a subscriber
issue number one for Nintendo Power I
still got that too
yo the to the power was so influential
back then yeah so influential oh yeah
I'm sorry it's how I started reading you
know it's it's like how I start kind of
you know I'll get back into it but like
it's how I started kind of getting into
like media and stuff like that you know
uh so we're from Nintendo to Super
Nintendo never had a Sega Genesis but
but you know uh I know I know my buddy
had it okay okay I grew up at Guam and
like oh you know like like you know with
Sovereign you're from Puerto Rico so
we're from the colonies too so
absolutely other side you know Guam
games were so expensive you know like
wow because it was import prices so I
used to pay like over 99 for for like oh
grandma was really rich
she actually got it for Japan
that was good yeah yeah so that was fine
um
after that it was 99 yeah 99 back and
back in the day you know I played Street
Fighter Street Fighter 2 Super Nintendo
it was like a hundred thirty dollars
Yeah well yeah that was definitely you
know what that's going rate because I
spent 150 in reported yeah yeah imported
well I mean he's paying import prices so
yeah that's basically you that's going
rate yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um how to Sega Dreamcast and I had a
Sega Center okay oh let's go because I
always wanted a Sega you know I always
wanted to say my buddy uh had a Sega
Genesis at a super famicom so I used to
go to his house all the time his older
brother used to cook meth so you know it
was always yeah yeah so that was it that
was it he was moving out here because we
was pocket watching we wanted to know
what was going on
that's how he had the Sega Genesis and
the super Fabrics
because it just almost went over my head
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you know Final Fantasy 7 like like that
I changed my world you know um
as a Nintendo guy right
didn't uh Sony when it when it came out
I mean it was really aggressive like
that PlayStation one was really
aggressive as far as Market penetration
games at launch but it it felt like the
Natural Evolution of Nintendo because a
lot of those franchises crossed over I
just want to know your thoughts like on
your first PlayStation and the initial a
Wonder of it because a lot of these guys
from this generation will probably never
understand how truly aggressive and
diversified Sony was at this point and
they had a real background in uh
presentation and theatrics
we've never had a game system like that
before like like when I saw Wipeout
with his with his Prodigy soundtrack
you know and the graphics and everything
that like that was crazy like we've
never seen like like like Sega CD tried
to to capture that Vibe you know but it
never really really did yeah because it
they didn't have the games to back it up
you know incomes PlayStation with like
games like like like like uh like like
Road rashes
[Music]
obviously too yes uh you know
we just never seen anything like that it
was a completely different it felt like
games were growing up with us yes yeah
that was a significant job yeah and so
people these days do not understand the
difference between like Final Fantasy 6
and Final Fantasy VII I say it all the
time I tell them all the time I tell it
the difference
well the difference is that you know the
older one is better but yeah yeah that's
not that's not as iconic it's
recognizable
let me put it to you this way in Final
Fantasy VI was all that it would be
Final Fantasy 6 on that Nvidia link and
not nine
this is not about they have to Pander to
you polygon boys
but people do not understand like how
when Metal Gear Solid came out I do not
understand how like like mind-blowing it
is that every single line in that game
is spoken yes that was crazy you know
like like when we when I heard Super
Metroid and like that that started off
with a voice I was like whoa
so like did you go from that to Metal
Gear Solid within like the space of like
you know like within the space of like
how much a triple A game is being made
these days yeah absolutely that's crazy
no you're absolutely right I mean I
remember Metal Gear just opening up like
a movie the way kajima just started
building up and then that was the other
one but I'm talking about the first one
when it was like oh it was just so I'm
talking about um
that was a graphical oh my God that's
what you threw the bodies inside
yeah
for sure so you know people people make
fun of PlayStation being the movie game
uh console but it's like look at what
metal gear solid what did from bad back
yeah like like that reputation was
always there and it was mind-blowing yes
crazy absolutely you know and I never
owned a Nintendo 64. okay
he lost me that generation you know he's
like I follow Final Fantasy I was like I
gotta follow Final Fantasy I'm sorry I'm
sorry wow so what was the last let's
back this up what was the last Nintendo
console pro at that time well before
this 64 was like the light was Super NES
your last what it was it was Super
Nintendo yeah and I said it's completely
skipped at 64. around that time I
stopped playing video games a little bit
okay around the time like like after
like the first year or two of
PlayStation yeah I stopped playing games
because I was in high school like like
like alcohol drugs girls absolutely all
right you was usually moving out here
he's real with it he real with it I'm
not gonna front this has been the best
this is the best
there's never been somebody that's real
yeah I mean he's up there now we get
past jaffee level
like right now
he's outside moving
and then I realize sex drugs
he was outside this is amazing the only
thing I feel for you though is that
which I'm with you a Nintendo did lose
me a little bit during the era I will
say though the analog was huge when I
saw that and then I remember you know
married 64. okay king showed it to me I
still played those I still played those
I I read it the I read it the console at
Blockbuster
yeah and if you was a wrestling fan I
was still diving in whenever I could
yeah and the wrestling games oh some
hockey games well well God tier like
they had to buy for the best wrestling
games period like on that console just
in general but anyway so you you did
that he was moving to shaking and then
you came back because you said you're
gonna follow the final fantasy series so
then PlayStation kind of got you back
PlayStation had me okay it was
PlayStation one PlayStation two you know
I had a Sega Dreamcast too of course
like I was like come on man like shed
move you know that was crazy
fanatic you know like I love Virtual
Fighter so like yeah yeah it's a Soul
Calibur those games back in the day
um and then but virgin fighter 4K the
PlayStation two you know so so I was
playing that like crazy PlayStation 2
PlayStation three when Xbox came out
like
I I I wasn't on Xbox day one but what I
heard about Halo and I saw Halo and I
was like the fat is the game that I need
right now that is I need that experience
right now I need an Xbox I don't care
what else is on it I need I need Halo it
worked it worked
and then so Xbox time you know so it was
Xbox Xbox 360. you know I got a
PlayStation 3 later and the Xbox 360. I
mean everyone did because 360 came out
first right yeah yeah
um and uh 360 love could be some some
joints for 360 that had you it was the
Bethesda game
wait wait are you implying that they've
been there the relationship has been
that long because people think that it's
like it's a manufacturing relationship
are you saying that this is organically
all the cops let me just stop
excuse me excuse me continue which but
that's the game I'm saying that it was
Oblivion it was Oblivion because I
played Morrowind you know and I was like
more one blew my mind I was like I never
played to get an RPG game like this
before I was like Olivia looks crazy so
Oblivion was an exclusive for the Xbox
360. it was uh and it worked so that's
why you know like we're gonna come up
and talk about it but like Starfield is
such an important exclusive for the Xbox
you know yeah absolutely yeah I remember
playing uh Oblivion with my cousin storm
and at the time we was like big in a
RuneScape it was like an MMO and we
would take turns for who's playing
RuneScape and who's playing more yeah
yeah I remember the the first time uh
Cog and I found this game called uh
Kings field yes from software
yeah it was it was from software I
remember because I imported it and
because we didn't we didn't brought
everything there so I was like what
should we get and you know we looking at
the box art and we're looking at the
back and Cog was like we should get this
I was like all right let's get it and we
got back home
and that was our introduction to Dungeon
Crawlers even though the the space was
it was moving really slow and stuff like
that but when we got Oblivion that was
the next step and and I hope I have that
same feeling with Starfield when it does
come out that uh that sense of wow
newness and and expansion and growth so
I hope so yeah for Western RPGs and just
what it was I was just amazed by like
the the the levels of systems that the
game had so that you would go into a
town and you know it's it but that's the
Gaze lets you interact with pick up
everything everything yeah like look at
somebody's house I mean somebody's house
looking at their books and take and then
they had a red icon never forget this
song and it was like would you steal
yeah off this table and I'm like what's
funny if you crouched on your your uh
your words says that you're aiming for
it would be an eye
if it's open it's like people watching
this
this game recognizes that I'm really
being shy Steep and then when you when
you when you had G when you had the idol
it was red in your inventory yeah and
then I came outside that person's house
in the village and the cop said yo right
here
I always thought it was funny because
the way Fable handled that like in the
original Fable they would literally be
on the map and it's like okay you
committed like 30 murders 15 assaults 20
breaking entries but you come back in
eight minutes they're gonna forget
I love I loved those systems and like
you said Gene like Bethesda they really
transform like the RPGs it was it was
crazy yeah shout the level just stop you
violated the law yeah continue continue
but yeah so you was doing and the guards
were so op at the beginning yeah you
could not but it was good and then you
start running through the town those
games are immersive Sims pretty much
that's what they are you could literally
create your own storyline with your old
stuff but I'm sorry G continuing going
on Oblivion for 360 Suburban 360. yeah
360 with PlayStation 3 Metal Gear Solid
4 was coming out so that's when that's
when I got the PlayStation 3 and then I
heard about a little game called Demon
Souls I was like wait that's from the
makers of armor Court I've been in front
of software fan from the beginning since
King's field so you know a lot of people
don't know a lot of people don't know
they made enchanted Arms that turned
yeah yeah yeah
I was like I was like I gotta play Demon
Souls like like this is like Demon Souls
looks like the dream game yes I was a
Souls fan from the beginning too I was
like like this is exactly it you know
and that's why when elder ring came out
I was like this is like like I'm in
heaven right now
through Dark Souls like that was the
first I remember people playing demon
shows but at the time like I didn't have
a PlayStation it was only on that and I
remember my friend John it's like man
just play Dark Souls and I remember
having that same mentality as people do
I'm not playing a game that's designed
to punish you
and now here I am like 15 games
that's why what bloodborne came up with
was announced for PlayStation 4. I was
like well I gotta go PlayStation 4 again
now too you know it makes sense
yeah Xbox One did all that back in the
day so like like he lost me yeah I did
not I did not return to Xbox until they
released the Xbox One X oh that's okay
correct for the Scorpio yeah yes that's
a good console and when I heard that Red
Dead Redemption 2 was 4k on the Xbox One
X I was like Red Dead Redemption 2 I'm
sorry it looks garbage on the PS4 like I
need that phone
I got the One X I got Red Dead
Redemption 2 I got what I needed it was
it was it was beautiful it was perfect
yeah absolutely yeah it did that for you
you know what I'm glad he said that I'm
glad he said you know I didn't waste my
time with the underpower with uh
Diversified uh console I went with the
op Xbox One X uh and I think that's when
Phil put his stamp like you know I'm
here you know type of thing you know
what kept the power narrative I I think
Phil knew when he took over that there's
a lot of bad stigmas and he knew even if
he continued that and didn't correct any
of them the next console would just get
those bad stigmas so he had to fix them
before the next console came out they
knew what the like Jay was saying with
the Xbox One how it started off and not
only was it the more expensive car so it
was less powerful so they wanted to try
to work on getting the power narrative
back in exactly yeah the Xbox One X was
that I'm sorry continue yeah the fact
that it was more powerful like like
reiterated to me okay Microsoft is still
into gaming you know yes they really
needed to Showcase that and I was like
okay well like like like I'll I'll get
back to invest investigating you know
Take Years forward like loved it played
Sunset Overdrive loved it I was like
wait a minute Xbox one had some amazing
exclusives
no that nobody is talking about Xbox one
it's sad it's sad you know yeah
absolutely right and and that that's the
unfortunate I remember the launch lineup
and I I had both and me and King we had
a ball it was just like we were like yo
they actually had it was a Dead Rising
Dead Rising yep
um yeah it it they really showcased the
system well so the launch lines were
better but then again the TV focus and
you know a lot of the mistakes that were
made and then when we find out obviously
about the the whole that was during the
1080p era and who was doing 1080P and
not that's when you started to see and
and we realized they didn't own they
didn't have control a lot of these great
IPS the sunset overdrives the quantum
breaks or whatever and that's when
you're like okay I Gotta See if they're
serious about gaming then Phil comes in
and I'm kind of aligned where you were
because yeah I was on the same boat with
them at that point yeah look look like I
I Am The Internet's number one defender
of Crackdown three oh my crackers
Crackdown three is so good to me yes to
me it kind of reminds me of two you know
like like I do feel like it deserves a
fourth one like look I think a lot of
the issues that game came with is the
over promising of the multiplayer and I
feel like if they would have took the
resources they tried to make that with
and put them all into the single player
we'd be having a different conversation
right now exactly I wasn't part of the
hype cycle though so that's why when I
play Crackdown three out and I heard
that Joe Stanton uh Joe Satan of Halo
you know he worked on that game too oh
that was good oh I think uh the tech
demo that they show with the cloud
computing yeah I think that hurt that
game more than anything else yep
I agree that's what she had everything
man I love to hear those stories I'm
surprised
that was able to get anything that they
wanted no man he was okay
everybody need that big homie
hey big homie crazy
minus the drugs
oh man anyway so he got tremendous
history I was surprised you didn't
mention a Resident Evil because I know
you're such a big Resident Evil oh bad
for places that like Resident Evil like
like I needed to play with PlayStation
one and then and then again that was
when I dropped off a gaming and so I
didn't even hear about Resident Evil 2
until like two years later oh wow like I
went to her friend's house and he was
like well they made a Resident Evil 2
and I played that out I was like okay I
gotta I gotta get back
um you would addict share a lot of the
Resident Evil love and King departs love
too so salute to y'all on that now I got
this tremendous game in history
obviously you talked a little bit about
having you know Nintendo Power before
Nintendo power so my question is like
okay what
was it always journalism for you like or
was there anything pre you know what we
know you for now like what was getting
their career started trying to figure
life out what were you doing at that
point it was always pretty much
journalism you know uh on Guam uh that
there's a there's a paper that used to
be owned by the same company that owns
USA Today uh connect
um and so I I interned for them during
High School like I was into writing like
like you know my full Christian name is
John Eugene Park the Eugene is named
after Eugene O'Neill to playwright
so I was always kind of like interested
in writing like it was like
predetermined for me and so when I saw
the internship for the paper like my
mom's was like you know why don't you
just apply it I was like okay why not
yes and I and then I did it and after a
year I was like you know what I'm I'm
pretty good at this it taught me how to
talk to other people you know because I
I I I I'm forced to interview people you
know so like it got me out of my shell I
used to be the kind of kid that would
like you know just like stay quiet look
at the ground and just just not say
anything but after I started getting
into journalism I was like I started to
literally find my voice you know
um
so I interned for the for the for the
for the local paper there Guam like I
even like when Bill Clinton came through
on Guam like I covered that wow you know
and I even got to meet Bill Clinton when
I was like 16 so that was crazy
um and then so I went to school Cal
State Fullerton you know nice Saloon
study journalism there uh Orange County
California yeah I interned I interned at
the Orange County Register the San
Gabriel Valley Tribune and I worked at
the daily Titan School paper um
never really thought about games media
at all like I did freelance during
college for a small website
um and that was like like I went to E3
back in 2002.
because he because he went when uh the
common people
yeah you can't let you gloss over that
yeah because King is right that was a
period three he's definitely that over
to a public I remember at that time okay
what are we still getting videotapes
we find out later what happened
I remember you talked about that last
week and I was like yeah I remember
getting those VHS VHS tapes too it was
like yeah those tapes and like add one
tapes and like yeah
that's the only thing that we had
factual shout out to them and one tapes
hot sauce so so you was you was privy to
a lot of those uh
After parties yes yes I went to the Xbox
like the original Xbox launch after
party the Cowboys okay the one that got
his man yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right don't let's slip out what
happened there but
okay so you you're in the know because I
like at that point in time I mean people
don't understand like because you know
now they get a chance to go to E3 they
take a lot of this stuff for granted you
guys were in the know like the stuff
that happened there and remember the
internet is not popping popping like
that as far as getting information to
you uh super timely like in seconds
it takes a little bit you guys really
got a chance to see the magic and the
Wonder and stuff in the background how
was that atmosphere at the E3 you know
for you as a journalist going through
with those wide eyes seeing everything
you know behind the scenes seeing the
magic I was fascinated I felt like I was
like like some kind of magical land you
know like yeah especially from Guam you
know like like Guam
guava is is we got nothing there you
know right so for me to travel to La
well go to school in La you know and
just meet on all these different types
of people that are that are just Brown
you know which is crazy
um and then but then to go to E3 to see
like the trailer for like Metal Gear
Solid three like the debut trailer for
that uh you know like I was in line to
see the the debut trailer for Halo 2. oh
oh my God oh my God that famous you know
that the Halo 2 had that documentary
where they had where they had they
showed the you know the The Joe satin
playing playing the demo yeah I saw that
demo live wow you know I was like
screaming my head off I was like I can't
believe this WOW but I got a back it up
though I saw Half-Life too oh my God you
know so what what was the energy I gotta
ask you this because Halo 2 was so huge
like what was the energy in the room
what did people really feel the way they
feel now like was it like yo this is
something special all over again yeah
yeah
it was it was it was crazy to this day
I've never been like like anywhere near
that kind of energy before you know
for Halo 2 you know people were
screaming as we left theater you know
like even before that it was crazy you
know that's insane man yeah you're out
of time and and what I remember the only
person I think kind of back in the days
that I used to was shot to my mother's
in uh nlg he used to go a lot of those
the traditional stuff from the e3s and
stuff like that but it was a different
energy and and it was obviously more
corporate more business more executive
focused like I guess my question for you
is I don't eat like my first YouTube is
like 2014 2015. yeah and my question is
like where was the energy still like I
know this little Fanboy aspects of it
and people act silly sometimes immature
like we're Executives acting that way
like I want to know what however was it
very more you know reserved you know
clean what was that I would say I would
say it was more reserved but this was
back in the day of the booth babes
remember that yeah like remember like
this was like a car show back in the day
yeah
that's what I was talking about exactly
so we had like half naked women like oh
it was like I was like 20 21. oh
yes sir
he said I was still
I had friends that came from out of town
like like you know other writer friends
and they're like like oh man like you
know like I got blue balls
so I took them to the strip club I took
them to the Spearmint Rhino in L.A yeah
I'm gonna tell you right now if y'all
not sharing this up hit the like button
so it's a question I'm Gonna Roll it
back a little bit you said your first E3
was 2002 right
so around that so did you ever go to a
CES I never I've never been to a CES
ever no okay because because you know
what's happening simultaneously with C
is right you know yeah it was wow what a
time
man but uh leading the witness yes he
definitely was leading the witness there
we go we go
I just wanted some stories and there
were stories to tell you I just wanted
to see how deep the rabbit
shout out shout out to G for doing the
Lord's work helping out his his friends
that were going through a tough time
dealing with some issues while they were
dead
I was the local guy you know
Gene
they're like this is ridiculous dude
that's ridiculous I got something for
you what I can discern is yes Gene
wherever he is he's gonna have a group
have a guitar
so okay so we got that and then I
received doing that so then now like
what then what leads up to what we kind
of know yeah journalism okay well so so
I so I went so I couldn't get a job in
California uh after school you know uh I
was not really homeless but I stayed in
my friend's garage for like six months
before I realized like okay I can't find
a job so I guess I'll move back to Guam
so I did and then the paper hired me
back there I didn't want to do that I
didn't want to go back to my hometown
you know
um I did that I did that for three years
hated it you know uh got into some
trouble for myself and then I met a girl
who was living in Hawaii and then so I
moved to Hawaii for her oh
um and then this was back in like 2006
2006 yeah so I lived in Hawaii from 2016
2015. okay
um and so I became a reporter there in
Hawaii too so I could I've covered crime
I've covered like small business
business uh military movements
um and like I've covered court stuff too
I've never covered for video games I've
never covered video games professionally
you know wow
um and then you know I got laid off in
2000 2009 and like I worked in like
health insurance for a bit you know like
and then like they hire me back but like
that that layoff taught me like gee you
got to learn some other skills you know
like you can't just like you can't just
be reporting and writing out here you
know because like like you got to make
yourself invaluable yes so I started to
learn like all kinds of other like like
trades like within The Newsroom and I
started to really get interested in
social media like you know back then I
was like you know what like this
internet thing social media like we need
to we need to get on it because like you
know like like we're behind the times
yeah journalism is right
so I became like the first social media
editor like in Hawaii yes and then like
like I did that for the paper and I did
that for a small like News website after
I quit the paper uh I worked at
government for like a month and a half
and then like Pierre midi are the the
founder of eBay he was starting up a
small like News website and he was like
hey I heard you the best of social media
like in news in Hawaii I was like yeah I
sure am so you know he's hired me nice
um and then it was through my work there
at a small website that I applied to the
Washington Post you know out of DC you
know it was always my dream my dream to
work at the LA Times yeah Los Angeles
Times I really want to work there but
you know I never even got an internship
there I never even got a call there but
for some reason the Washington Post was
interested so I was like okay I was like
I was I was like I guess this is the
moonshot I'll give it a shot right and
then and then and then they like what
they heard you know Washington Post
interview process was was difficult it
took three months and it was it was 18
interviews damn yeah wow
yeah yeah like most people do it's like
six or like maybe like 10 at most or
whatever right 18 was crazy but I got
but I got it like like like like like
they were they were to me so I was a
social media editor at the Washington
Post uh for four four four almost five
years from 2015 through
2019. and then around that time uh we
started to the The Washington Post
management started to look into covering
Esports
and then because the managing editor he
used to be our sports editor and he said
one of his biggest regrets was was was
sleeping on MMA
like like he was he was like you know
like this MMA thing isn't Gonna Last
whatever right yeah everybody said that
yeah everybody said that right and then
so he learned his lesson he was he was
he was like like I can't make that same
mistake again and the Esports is
obviously huge right so he started to to
form a committee within the Washington
Post kind of study like what would an
Esports section look like okay
out of board because like my background
and gaming and everything
I advise them Esports is great do not
only cover Esports because covering
covering only Esports that's not gonna
work because because that that that
field already has so much coverage
within the teams within the teams
themselves right influence themselves
like like it is a direct source of
information so like I don't think we can
contribute too much there right but if
you cover gaming as a broader culture
thing
that that would be that would be a much
bigger play and that that would that
would like that would gain a lot of
general interest readers a lot of young
readers so I was advising that and then
during that time I was also kind of
practicing writing the writing for
different sections I was writing for
like feature section I was writing for
the new section you know the Washington
Post like they need to trust you they
need to trust that that you can do the
reporting that you can be edited so I
was trying to build up that trust I was
being edited by other people I was
getting good traffic so you know when it
came time Emilio the editor who was you
know like like thinking about MMA and
thinking about Esports and now I'm
thinking about broader gaming coverage
she was like well now you know we're
gonna do this we're going to hire
someone say well [ __ ] why don't we just
hire Gene
bro that's how I got it that's how I got
it like I didn't apply for it I was
looking for it it was just something
that that I helped out do at the
Washington Post and I was like I was
like yeah this is it and you can
attribute that to feeling that feeling
that you felt before by you had to made
yourself indispensable so when you got
to the Washington Post you was at so
many different stations and so many
people heard your name and you built up
a level of credibility and and you know
and they respect your work yeah I mean
you know they gave that to you the thing
too is yeah very inspirational because
um his hustle his grind and we've all
been there with setbacks and and layoffs
and the frustrating thing is when you
you have a passion for something and you
have a dream but no one's giving you
opportunity right and you just you know
and then it's like the thing that you
said that really resonated with me was
having to go back to Guam right because
as men sometimes we it's like defeated
attitude like we really want to make it
it's not popping for me right now I got
to go back because we just we gotta we
gotta put food on the table we gotta
survive you know we can't we have to
live somewhere and to hear your story to
come full circle and then to to shoot
your shot get the Washington Post to
listen you know and then even your
hustle between you was out here you were
doing legal you would do it you was
moving you know what I mean so brother
that is extremely inspirational your
grind is insane and just to see that
lane open up and sometimes it's about
the right time Price Right Place the
right time because the pocket for gaming
then starts to open right they start to
see like hey maybe we need to cover this
and then you give them the direction
okay Eastport to school
but let's expand further than gaming but
that's very inspirational brother I'm
sorry I cut you off you know thank you
for saying that you know like like it's
been hard because like when I worked at
like papers in Guam and Hawaii like I
would always pitch like different like
internet projects and social media
projects and like other ideas and like
you know I'll get shot down like like
you know like my former Mentor would be
like Gene that is the stupidest idea
I've ever heard
wow what's this game that game it ain't
gonna do nothing
yeah so it was real bad sort of when I
got to the Washington Post I was like
these people are actually listening to
me
you know and like like but I have to
work for that trust in the Washington
Post Yeah I had it I had a weekly email
where I would like give advice uh on
social media and how to like write
headlines and all that stuff and then so
through that like like King said like
everybody got to know my name in The
Newsroom you know okay like like I was
playing politics we didn't yes sir
you can trust me I can I can deliver
this for you and I think you know so I
will work for like the foreign section
like the other day I I tweeted about
like how you know like we did we did the
first ever used live stream out in North
Korea
and I know that was dicey because like
her handlers didn't even know that she
was gonna do that you know so it's like
like this is North Korea like that's
dangerous as hell it's dangerous it was
really dangerous yeah
you know so I so I used to do stuff like
that like for like all kinds of
different sections and so like it was
like building that trust within the
Washington Post which is a very very
large organization
um and then for them to trust me it's
like okay Gene knows what he's talking
about in this regard and you know like
we trust his writing yes like like you
said like like I was talking about like
I really like I really tried to make
myself invaluable learning all these
skills learning how to talk to different
people so I got so I was able to finally
get to at the age of you know 38 I
became a games journalists absolutely
bro that's crazy and
um
and that that's the day and age when you
like if you want to really impress
somebody that's resistant to the change
that's coming this wave of like the
internet and this show them the power of
SEO and I know you did that I know you
said okay okay let's change this title
around a little bit and look at how many
people look at this as opposed to before
and all you got to do is end once they
start seeing dollar signs it's like
every single door opens up what that's
what I did and the Hawaii a small
website with the eBay guy uh you know
they wanted to be like investigative and
like you know cover government and stuff
like that I was like okay well the stuff
that we're doing isn't really getting
traffic why don't we like take that kind
of lens and look at like The Wider life
of Hawaii you know and like things about
the wider life and why that people might
not people might not be thinking about
it but they want to know about so I
pitched a story I did because everyone
in Hawaii likes to park backwards they
like Park that car backwards so I was
like why do we do a story about why
everyone Hawaii likes to park
it's interesting let's just talk to old
people let's talk to people who who made
parking lots back in the day and let's
figure this out boom it within like
three hours it became our number one
story wow and I was like I was like
that's what I'm talking about that's
exactly what I'm talking about you know
like each brother you need to brought it
out you need to make these stories
interesting yeah interesting it's a good
point you're absolutely right these are
these are lessons you know to be learned
and then occupied and having that
ability for your thoughts and earning
that trust to be heard is super
important so what a salute you did
another thing I want to salute you and
you kind of so I've kind of alluded to
it you were kind of alluded to it is I
know you viciously defend games culture
which we love about you you know you're
willing to to mix it up for the debate
every now and then you know what I'm
saying which also respect about you but
the thing that to me is most interesting
impressive about you that I look at from
a professional journalism is that
you consider the content
and the the content creator and the
influencer like the rock star
and to me that's unique because in this
current climate I feel like there's a
divide right now right where the journey
yeah most of them don't respect us
exactly where the journalists is like
hey I went to an accredited school I
went I got my degree I'm a journalist
you are an influencer
provocateur see because shout out to
Jason
but I could
respected process well I understood it
but oh here we go time out now oh let's
go who's that so
um
[Laughter]
that's
that's that like you look at you know us
so to speak as as like you know the rock
stars and my my question to you is like
what's your thought process there
because a lot of people don't have that
say don't share that mindset that you
have being from where you're from
Washington Post in the prestigious
nature of that
well for me like I've always been I'm
super concerned about the trust level of
journalism right like people because
people don't trust us you know and I've
said this before I've said this before
in like panels like two other
journalists I was like I do not think
that we can rebuild the trust that we
have lost in the last generation for
like another generation or two like I
will probably be dead before journalism
can can can earn that trust back again
like I'm just I'm I'm just being real
you know that's true and that trust has
gone to the creators and to the to the
influencers you know for Like For Better
or Worse you can complain about it all
you want you complain about it all you
want you know and people do but that's
just that's just the reality of it you
know and it for me
when I wanted to get into journalism I
wanted to cover I didn't want to cover
games I wanted to cover music I wanted
to cover I wanted to cover cover rock
bands I wanted to cover hip-hop groups
you know like you mentioned like like
Three Six Mafia I come I covered Three
Six Mafia I was in the backstage with
them like hanging out with them and I
was like so I saw that pictures with you
a Juicy J yeah I was kind of lit yeah I
was kind of lit back there yeah
me and Juicy J we were partying and like
and I was like I was like oh
exactly what I wanted in life
I want to be hacking with with Juicy J
yeah
you have definitely floated yourself all
the way to the top spot because he said
I have reached my Pinnacle in life I
just wanted to hang out with Juicy J oh
God
these recipes oh I'm sorry but continue
to continue this is some real talk it's
a real talk I did not mean gangster boo
you know that's it yeah
we should follow me back on Twitter each
other a few times so you know like like
you know I feel blessed that's what's up
people acknowledged me but like I
watched covering music but then for me
like I started to look at wait a minute
the real rock stars in this day and age
are the creators
the guitar or bass or and be a lead
singer for Rock Band anymore they want
to be on YouTube they want to be on
Twitch and like like you look at all
these cohort these groups of of creators
in California you guys like last time
media like like there are groups of
creators everywhere that is like you
know like like just like like clicks of
like you know like like
just on top of my head like Jay-Z and
Kanye or whatever like that you know
yeah you know so it's like for me like I
I see that I see that happening nobody
wants to become a rockstar anymore
everyone wants to become a Creator and
and that's been the case for like the
last several years it's not changing so
do before I give it to you I just got
one quick question follow up and then
I'll give it right to you do you think
it's a really I'm kind of calling it The
Great Divide right where again you have
the traditional journalist and then you
have the rise of the content creator the
influencer so do you think it's the the
older regime kind of holding on to
traditional ways and not trying to
accept them do you think there's any way
we bridge that Gap though
I don't know a man because like like
I would love for the guy to be bridge
but like you know broadcast music you
don't do it you know broadcast music
like CNN isn't going to go on Twitch
ever ever you know because because that
those numbers on TV is what matters to
them right you know that all that
matters to them yeah uh you know like
like I look at the New York Times like
like like like they're barely getting it
like the Washington Post like like I
work at the Washington Post and I'm
still struggling within the Washington
Post to get it to do certain things you
know
um and like you know I have to say that
it's a personality personality driven
information uh uh uh market right now
you know and to be quite honest like
journalists for decades have been have
been trained to like get rid of their
personality you know like a robotics
yeah yeah I'm live here reporting from
the iron Lord podcast
so dude I have to ask you because you
specifically say loss of trust right
yeah and that would indicate that
something had to happen to lose that
trust as opposed to just things changing
and you know new people doing things
differently kind of moving into place
and and journalists losing influence so
specifically like where do you think the
loss of trust comes from because that's
just different than losing influence
yeah I think I think it's because we
keep threatening you know we keep we
keep pretending that we don't actually
like like know anything about like we
don't have any actual feelings about the
story right
uh and like people are done like we
could we could we could see it like like
you're you're pretending to not to do
this or that you know and like
pretending you're saying one thing and
then and and another thing says oh I'm
Fair it's like everyone knows that
you're not you're not you're right right
you know so you know and then the way
they cover certain communities whether
it's communities color or even white
people too you know either way uh or
like it's always about parachuting in
and parachuting out like they never
really understand the communities that
they're in
um especially in the national news so
like when when people cover gaming like
they just say oh let me just check out
like like a subreddit and then and then
I I got it all you know yeah you gotta
immerse yourself in the culture and
that's the thing right you have to be
part of it to get that sort of respect
words I I think again a lot of people
that work at these bigger Outlets do
have that like you have that
um but it is the thing like it's
different that if you're reporting on
like you know the war in Ukraine or
whatever yes it's understood that you're
reporting on it as objective be as
possible from a distance you're not in
it for the most part so yeah this is
different because this is a hobby that
requires that like you have to be part
of it yeah no doubt you had a question
I'm sorry
yeah I think a lot of it has to do too
is they see like journalists and stuff
they they don't see the individual
journalists they just see the website
they're working for like when you see a
review on IGN they don't see it as that
individual person they just see IGN
review such and such and you know when
it comes to like yeah you know yeah yeah
yeah
it comes to like influencers you're
seeing them you're seeing streamers like
I know like uh you know Valkyrie Aiden
Ross like all of them like you're seeing
them play the game you're seeing them
review the game and I think that's why
because it's more intimate it's like you
know you you are actually seeing the
person and for the most part you look at
like IGN reviews any kind of review like
even you know video reviews you don't
see the actual person most of the time
it's just some gameplay some voice and
then you know not to mention you have
stuff that goes on where you find out
this person wrote it but this person
voiced it and then it's just like
exactly that's weird and it's just like
that slowly it's like well you know this
review might have been written by this
and invoiced by this but I know this
person did both yeah yeah no it's real I
mean it's it's like I said I wanted to
commend you on that because it's rare
that I see you know the way you embrace
it I think it's different from from the
majority of your colleagues and I think
to be honest it is right I see that too
you know yeah it's part I think it's
part of of your your success in the way
you handle yourself I think people
really gravitate towards you because of
that as well I've heard people like
journalists say that they don't even
think like influences and deserve to be
like e3s and stuff like I've heard about
conversations like that go down I I will
say this right
um
because I can see both sides of the
fence I can see you struggling you you
you're breaking your butt you're doing
everything that you possibly can to get
into this business you're going to
school you're going getting into debt
you're doing uh intern Services you
don't got this guy coffee for so damn
long and you know he's still not looking
at the piece that you put on his desk
those type of things you know and you're
putting up with a lot of stuff and then
you look over and there's this kid on
YouTube who uh covers the same story
that you left on the desk and he's
getting a different type of light and I
can see uh he didn't earn it in your
eyes but you took a different approach
you looked at what made these
individuals special right because it is
some form of craft to be able to get up
and to get on a microphone and to carry
a conversation and to bring across uh
some type of
um
your personality to the to the piece
because it is a it's a peace giving from
that person not necessarily the same way
that you would give a piece so that's
why I give you guys reverence because
you did go through the stuff you went
through the mud and you know I do accept
some of the titles that are given to us
but I do love the fact that you you
Embrace Us in that manner and you give
that respect right back and not to
mention I do feel like journalists since
I have a better safety safety net than
like a lot of YouTubers and streamers
that's like huge and you you know you've
got plenty of money back you can invest
the money YouTube goes down there's a
lot of people
that's true at least like a journalist
or someone that actually has a backing
like a degree or something like they can
use that leverage to go somewhere else
maybe not in the gaming initiative or
something else like YouTube goes down
it's just a rap for a lot of people like
it's over yeah well that thing about
journalists is that you know a lot of us
are getting laid off whether it's in
game space or even in the regular
newspapers too like you know like like
like there's a lot of that but King I'm
glad also you said that you know uh I'm
glad you mentioned that it takes a lot
of talent to to do what you guys do you
know uh it really it really really does
it's exhausting I tried to stream uh
regularly and like like you don't really
know until you know you know so it's
like it's like I said earlier it's like
like you can't really
like you can't judge judge it but like
you really know when you when you give
it a shot
yeah when you're in it when you're
really trying to make that hustle when
you try to get when you try to earn
every single viewer you know with every
single of your accounts
that that that's that's so much work you
know so I have to respect you so much
you know I always say like the I have a
controversial question form okay okay I
say mine before you go to the rabbit
hole real quick
this is a deep question and I saved this
uh when I knew he was going to have you
on okay so I I always say like the
hardest thing hard of mental barrier to
break down in YouTube is talk like
speaking into a mic and talking to no
one right because because it's hard to
like visualize that's why I always say
like
streaming and solo podcasting some of
the hardest things you'll do in this
content yeah that's why uh combat talk
with the king is crazy
salute to you salute to you so
my question to you is how do you feel
about the rise of artificial
intelligence and in many of our uh
that's a concern yeah our artistic and
journalistic uh
uh Avenues are being given to this AI
like because I've seen AI write pieces
I've seen AI make art uh so what is your
thought on that because I deal with
um
the logistics of newspapers and stuff
like that in in the same area right so I
know when we were at our Peak and where
we are now
and jobs are being cut uh at an
astronomical rate right the production
of papers are not as high as it used to
be and uh these uh magazines and papers
are diversifying by going digital as
well to keep the writers and stuff like
that like you guys on but with the event
of the with the invention of AI that
threatens that market how do you feel
about that encroaching on your
livelihood
well uh it's just interesting to say
that because the Washington Post has
been using AI to write some stories uh
there's there's Sports stories right
just just game scores this game happened
this is this is the data it just
crunches it down and sometimes that's
all you need you know and that's all and
that's all we use it for I'm you know to
what we've been talking about that's why
personality is so important you know
because I don't I don't know how how
much further we can go with AI you know
obviously I'm afraid of it too right but
but that's that's what that's why
personality and being yourself and and
being being a person is so important you
know you can't just be like because
think about the mentality it is where
it's like you know oh we could just
replace the reporter with the AI because
that person had no Personnel
nothing to offer yeah
where that person went to the to the
football game wrote down the scores came
back and wrote a story you know do we
need to do that or can we just have an
AI do that you know right you know do we
need to pay that person health insurance
[Music]
so there are ways to to to to use it
smartly
um you know yeah but but again that's
why that's why being being Gene Park
instead of just being a reporter
reporter for the Washington is important
I got to be me no matter what you know
absolutely and like you said about being
indispensable and skill sets and and
other things like that another question
a couple questions I want to follow up
before we move on is um you know one
thing that I really respect about you is
how you kind of besides the the
consecrated the respect you have that
you have a very passion for like music
in video games and I think me and you
kind of share that and um I think a
quote you said video games are close to
the rock and roll or hip-hop a living
culture in which about 2 billion humans
on Earth participate so yeah yeah tell
me about this like why why does this
resonate with you and then also
specifically why does Music In general
resonated through a game and then also
specifically you you know the fact of
hip-hop it gaming as well because some
people are resisted when they hear
hip-hop in in gaming sometimes so tell
us about that your thoughts on both of
those well I mean I grew up in the in
the era of like you know a group of
other people and I probably said to
myself where it's like rappers crap you
know
wow like like you probably haven't heard
that like in years before but like I
still remember when people used to say
that and then so when I finally started
listening to hip-hop I was like this is
just actually like a new kind of music
and a low end Theory yeah
you know like Public Enemy like I met
you before too you know uh so
like I was like this is the energy
that's good that's going to bring about
change this is the energy that culture
is built around you know and that's the
same thing about uh with gaming too you
know that's why I I look at influencers
like rock stars like for me it's just
a different kind of vibe you know
and like you know even hip-hop is is is
is is is is is is it what it used to be
yeah it's strange uh it's it's crazy out
there the how much you have to hustle
for like every single Spotify stream you
know
that's why there's a modern culture
happening in the music too you know yeah
in that space too in a creative space
they are using AI like the AI rapper
that they use and like we're never going
to see artists hit that Milestones of a
million albums so our artists will never
go Diamond again off of sales you know
um I just noticed that uh the baby and
NBA young boy just so probably 40 000
copies and that was considered a win you
know where forty thousand copies of uh a
piece of music uh your album
before would be you would be banished to
to uh some other side label yeah you
know you can sell that out of your trunk
um yeah the way that we're streaming and
we're consuming all this information and
stuff like now has really changed so
yeah music is definitely a part of it
but the way we consume it is completely
different now yeah I'd imagine imagine a
game selling 40 000 copies oh my God you
know well you I think we will probably
get there as far as physical copies
right because we yeah you know and what
I'm saying is we know that streaming is
definitely up through the roof right so
people stream the album completely
different opposed to and they get a la
carte so those throwaway songs that you
know people will put on an album that
you would skip uh you can't do that
anymore you got to have like seven good
songs that you can put out so they can
stream all at the same time and you know
the album says so we'll see a decline in
physical copies but uh increase in
digital because yeah that's right that's
why there's so many EPS these days too
yes you do see so many albums with only
seven eight tracks yeah
no is is dope and what you mentioned and
and how you kind of champion and as far
as the gaming and music and and the
importance and significance to it it's
funny because I'm kind of the same and I
want to see more of it and I'm excited
for quote-unquote project Shaolin and
some other things I remember the Def Jam
jeans from back in the day you know what
I'm saying guys so I was following your
tablet you had you had shouted out all
the e for Rough Riders uh Jay that you
remember connections with Street Fighter
and stuff like that as well yeah okay
exactly you know I've been talking to
the rappers that that did the uh the
street fighter 6 saw you know so I'm
hoping to do something with them too you
know so yeah so like I'm deeply
connected to like music and games like I
I've interviewed like one of my career
highlights is I've interviewed Rizza and
Giza oh
um
yeah that they were doing a a
fundraising stream uh uh playing chess
you know so I talked to them about about
their chess their chess game and you
know like what they got going on and it
was just it was just a dream come true
for me oh that's fine salute salute you
don't see it it's the last point
question I have for you is um I'm always
serious no obviously you know you gave
the community you know a serious time to
reflect last year you know and we saw a
video it was called a cancerous G and it
was very touchy a lot of people rallied
behind you you know when you kind of
brought forth to the public your
diagnosis you know since then you know
you made the announcement that you're
now cans for free so I wanted to ask you
though just like that Journey from
obviously being diagnosed and just the
physical and mental stress required for
you to come back to where I go back to
the post and do what you love because
that was tremendous brother
it's crazy you know like I went through
so many body changes in the last six
months and the fact that I was able to
have surgery in late November to to
revert all those changes back to you
know my my body just being kind of
normal you know so like I I lost a foot
of my of my colon you know so like like
the food truck food travels a little
shorter
that's about it you know and I lost part
of my bladder so I pee one more time
throughout the day but that's that's
that's the that's the most effective
I've had you know other than you know
continuing to monitor uh making sure
that that I stay cancer-free because you
know recurrence is always an issue with
all of us
so uh but yeah I I can't even I can
barely process what happened the last
several months you know and I I think I
feel like I'm still in that process of
like
trying to like figure figure out how to
approach it but that's why me going back
to work was so important
yeah yeah like I can distract myself
like like my life is no longer just
defined by I had cancer you know yeah
like my life is defined by oh I got this
project I got I got this coming up you
know like I I I had my interview with
Neil druckman that's something where he
was outside baby
amazing interview
yeah I had I had that working like like
as I was in recovery because I was like
you know like I want to come back to
work and I want to hit the ground
running I want people to I want people
to see me
get in the ground running you know I I
wanted that to I want it to be seen like
that
you wanted to make sure that they know
the champ didn't lose a step exactly
exactly it was absolutely a show like
like a flex of strength like I'm like
I'm like I'm good I saw you pull up you
had the J's on you know what I'm saying
one of the pictures I was like okay the
swag is right the boys listen man
Chicago lost and founds yeah
he's he
I real recognize and ladies and
gentlemen this was G Park's last episode
on Island
we regretfully like to inform you face
this fashion
I told you real recognized real oh man
absolutely G you know my brother tremend
this history I mean I could talk to you
for I was so much more but we'd be five
hours a kid we can't do that yes sir so
um what we're going to do is a question
that we asked every member I'm guessing
around
I need more jeans top five exactly check
this out all franchises of all time
uptime top five video game franches of
all time that's a good one
um number one uh would be Resident Evil
whoa
surprising for me to say because I would
be like oh zeldor Souls which are like
not my number two or three right but
like when I think about it I have played
more Resident Evil than I played
anything else
series I go back to like every few
months it is a series I go back to
whenever I'm feeling down press whatever
I need to like like like distract my
mind like I know like the Resident Evil
puzzles and like for me like that
comfort of like just being able to like
put things where they need to be you
know like that's what Resident Evil
that's what Resident Evil always is
right like you got to put the green
Jewel yeah
so like that like just that that's just
comforting also like a pop of a zombie's
head you know oh yeah that's always
satisfying
Resident Evil I would say number two is
the soul series you know the from soft
Soul series uh David Souls Dark Souls
one two three failed it up you know
Elder Ring Of course too
um
you know again those games are like like
like therapy for me where it's like you
know like especially Dark Souls one
where I know like exactly what I need to
do in Dark Souls one like it's like I I
still like Dark Souls one more than
Elder ring because Elder is just too
damn big you know
there's just too much to do where it's
like okay like like that's that's not
comforting because I I because I know
like okay there's like like 10 000 miles
ahead of me yeah whereas in dark we're
in Dark Souls I know I know the the
journey from beginning to end yeah
that's exactly all right so we got that
number three will be Zelda you know uh
okay what more can be said you know
uh you know I even like Twilight
Princess and I gave Twilight princesses
an eight back in the day what did you
get a Skyward Sword
I I didn't review Skyward Sword back in
the day but I hated skywards
before you start cheering yeah until the
re-release on the twitch and I was like
actually this game is brilliant like I
just need to get rid of the motion
controls that's it he agrees with addict
though no I'm cool with that I don't I
don't care as long as they say it's
brilliant that's exactly what I said
like look like I feel like people get
out of me because I I I'm not the
biggest fan of breath of the wild
because I don't feel like it it's the
foundation of Zelda there's like a lot
of things missing about Zelda about that
French that game
and people's like oh what do you talk
about but then when I played Skyrim so
I'm like see these are temples this is a
well thought of story it's like breath
of the wild is literally okay the swords
over here there's random mouths
continue
uh number four and five is tough uh
uh gosh it'd probably be something
Capcom you know I see I see a specific
arcade unit behind you yes that's a big
blue arcade cabinet with Street Fighter
2.
Edition turbo and dark stalkers in there
so um
okay so edit number five will be Halo
okay okay uh uh I I I I I I I love
everything I love the show you know I I
I don't love loving is too much yeah
yeah yeah but I thought the show was
entertaining okay fun right and and it
was you know it has entertaining to talk
about I don't know about watching
anything to talk about too it's like
like even it's stupid stuff because I
acknowledge that like like like 70 of it
is is really dumb right
like there's 30 that's interesting and
cool and like the 70 that's dumb and bad
at least it's like fun or funny to talk
about you know so I think me and you
[ __ ] is is like just sometimes I could
appreciate just because there's a video
game with adaptation just made on
sub-level that I'm I'm already
interested you know I'm already
interested my bar is a little lower
because I'm just happy I mean I wouldn't
see what y'all doing and with the
references and stuff like that so yeah
like I like like like are you guys are
you guys gonna have fun with this right
then I'll have fun with it you know
that's it that's a doubt no doubt
surround and I watch every single video
game adaptation ever made you know like
okay I I I even did like an Oscars uh
article where it's like okay this is the
best director this is the best like like
actress and like all the video game
movies ever you know that that kind of
thing that's what's up oh that's just I
gotta check that out I don't even know
about that and our favorite console of
all time and why
I think that's an easy one I think
that's actually the Nintendo switch
yeah
yeah and it's only why it's only because
it's so stacked with like a lot of
modern Classics yeah Dark Souls you know
you got a Zelda breath of the wild tell
them why tell them why breath of the
wild tell them
because I do I do think that it is
foundational to the first game you know
and the routine that's foundational to
link to the past which is like which is
like a beautiful template I love it you
know but but but that's the template but
breath of the wild was a template for
Zelda one and that was something that
got me into it you know okay but the
switch has Doom it's got Witcher 3 yes
it's got dark it's called kickness three
there's ports over there it is I mean
they're smeared in Vaseline
Gene has to wear his glasses when
playing games
all the Nintendo games too so for me I
think it might actually be like if
there's gonna be one console that I'll
keep for for the rest of time at this
point at this point it would be the
switch yes overall like I think in terms
of like
a long history of of consoles so it
would have to be the PlayStation too oh
too yeah
uh the diversity in it like the the
amount of games that it had like I can't
even I can't go I can't even begin to
like like to count out the number of
games on the PS2 so and no doubt no
doubt and they're gonna stick this one
your top journalistic moment I know
Juicy J is up there but um top
journalistic moments as a journalist
what was those uh I think the most
that I'll say one reason when and like I
don't get I don't get enough flowers for
this one it was I was the first I was
the first mainstream journalist to cover
the metaverse
just like before like Facebook and Mark
Zuckerberg like like started to like run
his mouth about like you know like like
changing his company into like the
metaverse company or whatever like that
no comments yeah you know like like so
that's why I look at fortnite you know
like like Alex says he's in love with
fortnite I was I was I was hugely
addicted to fortnite right and then and
then like I definitely saw the metaverse
possibilities there so I want to chase
that story I talked to Tim sweetie out I
talked to like all these different
people and I was again I was the first
person to kind of see this this change
of the internet and for me like that
story came from like this passion of
like okay well journalism dropped the
ball when it came to to being caught up
on the Internet about it and it is about
to change and we still have it caught up
with the regular internet today like
journalism is gonna be dead in like 10
20 years like so that's that's where my
mentality is fine we're like like I'm
running around newsrooms saying the
metaphors is coming the metaverse is
coming and none of you are ready
the British are coming I like that I
like that
two lights shining
I was like nobody is ready for this
nobody is ready nobody's ready for the
metaverse you know and people were
talking about crazy I think everybody's
concerned we're trying to shut it down
and not trying to make that be the thing
I think that's yeah
that's salute to Eugene or being honest
I imagine we can definitely change that
subject though I'm sure that's very good
we could definitely move on for me but
um now let's salute that you mention
tremendous history you know we can talk
forever the amazing G part hopefully
Still rocking for us was still a topic
or two which would be great but um yeah
man I loved it we definitely kids your
spirits here so much history The Journey
has been absolutely tremendous we're
gonna talk more and uh let's get these
topics us off um I'm gonna get a couple
of chats with the topics yeah sure and
then I'm gonna take a quick bladder
break while we do yeah
we have a bee Lou member for 16 months
Lord bronze Lords you are appreciated
King now that uh big Frank got cut you
think we're gonna get him versus Fury
y'all got a Discord for supporters
question keep killing it foreign
I don't know maybe hopefully hopefully
we get that
definitely a Discord though
had if you could just put that info in
the chat addict I appreciate that we got
pixel bit G pixel bit G member for 37
months Lord bronze uh shout out to you
sir appreciate you then we have hargit
Chennai member for one year ten dollars
for the chat What gene is describing for
Halo 2 the hype the energy that's what I
want Xbox to do for Starfield why don't
we have that any why don't we have that
anymore Phil make it happen bring the
energy launch party IOP dominance it's
not like that that's not you can't
manufacture fake hype
the the trepidation that people have
with Starfield is because there wasn't a
star field before it the reason why Halo
2 was so incredible is because we were
seeing if it can live up to what Halo 1
did so maybe Starfield 2 will generate
that hype but exactly Starfield one has
to be Halo yeah
it's equivalent to like the new Zelda
and the new God of War like Can it can
it relive what it did in a couple years
ago the difference between and I can
tell you exactly why got a DLC fell flat
oh Lord
I can tell you exactly why
Halo 2
did stuff different gave you some of the
same
dual welding
they just went above and beyond the
world seemed bigger more vibrant better
um God of War played it safe that's all
that's that's what I'm saying so it felt
like more of the same
and you just were linked to the story
you just wanted to see what's the end of
this story because it was just felt like
the game was in the way of the story in
my opinion that's all it's also a
different place in time like we are back
then you didn't have the information
flow that we have now where people if
you're in if you want to be in the know
you're going to find out a lot about
this game before it comes out yeah um
whereas back then like you're only
really seeing what they give you and so
yeah the ability to build a pipe and the
desire for people to go out and stand on
the line and be be part of an event is
different than it is now it just doesn't
happen anymore you know you don't see
those huge launches for consoles and
stuff like that where you have you know
a thousand people on the line This
doesn't really happen anymore so we had
that that level of hype might be there
for a game like Starfield even not it
being an unknown quantity
all right
we got necromancers they all remember
for 14 months Lord gold here's to
another great show thanks for the
advanced GG code ordered gummies and
hydration
and we and we have Jesus two dollars in
the chat thanks for being the goat Gene
yes this is a this is a goated episode
yeah you had to be here for this past
all my expectations
remember for two years two dollars for
the chat it's confirmed that stalker 2
is now XBox XBox exclusive and PC only
we'll see this one might be the rdna2
stuff
um
[Music]
then we have eliad slobovich member for
two years I 15 I forgot what the it's
the rupees it could be yeah uh Happy
Lord's Day definitely following Lord
Jean after this great appearance on IOP
thanks to IOP for the content as usual
2023 up to off to a great start yes it
is well you wasn't following Lord you
better get on that Jay Park stop playing
yeah
hello and we have four as a legend
member for two years two dollar Super
Chat EA is a huge influence on hip-hop
and on hip-hop and video games yeah back
in the day you know something that was
back in the day when I first heard yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the musical
yeah shout out to 2K they'd be having
stuff too yes sir we have that after NBA
Live um
I started getting into rock music
because I'm at it I was like yeah it
would have like a little Joyce playing
in the menu they play it so many times
in the menu you want to download it I
was like whose machine had it
what's this
I was kind of jamming I ain't gonna
front
then we have uh Forza Legend again
remember for two years five dollars of a
chat the F Jam fight for New York is
probably the most requested remake of
all time
also NBA Street Volume 2 NFL Street Need
for Speed underground one and two big
hip-hop games yeah
fight for New York they gave you like
like you not only got a custom character
but you can like custom like your moves
like yeah you can hold them from like
the other Fighters that you can make
your own country your own character oh
that was amazing yeah like like there's
no other game that does that besides
like the upcoming Street Fighter six
that's coming out this year
fight for New York did that back in the
day yeah you know talk to him talked
loved that game love that game no we
have the ever-born Saga member at a five
dollar Super Chat Sonic Frontiers is
greater than the Skyward Sword tell King
I want all the smoke oh the numbers
would not indicate that sir I think you
need to stand down and down sir you know
when you fix the Overworld
slide bro
you're about to smoke for Sonic no doubt
continue and we have long Net's finest
Lord Flames five dollar Super Chat good
afternoon I hope he I hope everyone is
doing well it's fantastic having the
legendary Gene Park in the realm he is
an inspiration to us all yes he does he
is yes he salute the flame assistant out
of the Lord's gaming that next salute
brother and we are caught up all right
um last week's probably supposed to end
the people spoken with the rumors of an
Xbox game showcase imminent which do you
feel should be Xbox's primary focus or
the show's Direction the winner of the
four-way aisle people almost a deadlock
with 41 second place was 39 but with 41
of the vote was wanting a road map for
2023 with release dates so that's what
they want coming in at second place 39
of the vote was updated gameplay
trailers for redfall Starfield Forza and
potentially a new IP in third place with
a very close 11th well actually not very
close that was not falling 11 of the
vote was I don't care but oh he's I
don't care but I better not hear I need
to wait until 2024 for these games
and in last place with eight percent of
the vote would separate Starfield for
its own deep deep dark show which
actually ended up happening so
um your attic your thoughts on on the
people they they want the road map they
want the release that's what they want
from this this developer Direct
well we're gonna get the road map for
all of them but Starfield
no doubt so let's lead right into it so
um I'll set you up out of this your
topic I'll just give you the um official
press release shout out to Xbox news at
xbox.com Xbox wire Xbox and Bethesda to
present the developer direct live stream
on January 25th and it's called
obviously the developer direct and
presented by the game creators
themselves from Studios such as Arcane
Austin Mojang Studios turn 10 Studios
Max online the developer direct will
focus on big features extended gameplay
showcases and latest info for Xbox games
launching in the next few months
including the Elder Scrolls Online Forza
Motorsport Minecraft Legends and redfall
and they said to dedicate the proper
amount of time for a deep dive into
Bethesda game Studio star field a
standalone show is in the works and then
to follow up with uh Lord Greenie Aaron
Greenberg on Twitter he said that and
since many folks have asked our show is
tracking 43 minutes long so um yeah he
says outline in this announcement our
goal has been to be as transparent as
possible on what the devs and teams and
the games to expect to see in this show
so this has hit the interwebs uh added
this is your topic how you approach it
man
I just want the general you know
impression of the Lords and uh Lord Gene
you know I I still I I
I'm okay with them coming out and saying
like look don't expect star food here
I understand the decision behind it I
understand it's a big game but at the
same time
I don't agree of not having here in any
way shape or form you can easily show
this game in some way if it's a new
trailer some kind of you know maybe
minute trailer with I prefer release
date and then it's like you know if you
want to see more in depth on this game
we got an event for you and then they
show the release date to that event uh
it's just I just feel like
it really makes me think this game's
getting pushed back to late 2023 because
it's just like
I don't understand why you're bringing
this to the FL to the front and these
games are supposed to come out in the
next five months
so implying that the the development I
mean the marketing cycle might not be
time enough if it's coming what are we
doing at it what you saying unless
I don't think we're going to get the
the uh the actual event for Starfield
next month because at that point
maybe it's just a time restraint or
anything like that but it's just like
maybe we'll get like the beginning of
March
I I don't know because like it's just
it's just weird it's like you heard the
same thing right Gene
you're trying to make it funny dude I
see what you're doing
it's just this is your biggest game this
year
this is the game everyone's asking for
this is the game that people
realistically expected at the Video Game
Awards and this is the only game you're
not shown like and like cool I get it
it's a big game you want to give it
enough time to really unwind unwrap
Starfield but you could easily do that
and still have star fill out this event
I'm not giving them that excuse you
could easily have Starfield at that this
event because it's coming out this six
months allegedly
and you can easily still look but we're
gonna have a breakdown next month the
month after that but here's what you
needed to know here's when it's coming
out
and if you want to see more information
on this game you can watch that event
when that event goes up just to be clear
before we open it up to Gene uh yo they
stupid 108 he said attics world is in
full effect I haven't heard that in a
while but look at the fairness to my bed
it's my man
so your concern is because they even
though they set expectation about saying
that it's not going to be at this event
you're concerned that it not being at
this that something is up as far as the
release no no nothing even that it's
like look like people expected this it's
a video game awards and when we didn't
see it at the Video Game Awards we were
told it's soon now we get this event
that soon and it's still not at the soon
event that we were teased a month ago
that there are more information
they said but they said we will show you
more and everyone is looking for Star
filled well sure people are excited
about red balls
about about Minecraft Legends but
everyone is looking for Starfield and
they came out there and they said we
will have more information on you guys
shortly and then when we get more
information oh but we got way longer for
that one like no like it would be
different this game would come out in
November and we knew it was coming out
November okay you got plenty of time but
you didn't mean to tell me this game is
supposed to come out in five months and
we and at the end of this month we're
having an event and we're still not
seeing this game so they could have
trouble like a month trouble in Paradise
that was wrong are they gonna have like
a month of marketing before the game
comes out because that's the greatest
marketing ever
look at me Atticus okay let's open it up
first what's up with G Lord Gene um I'm
going back to my grapes
is first of all about to develop a
direct announcement you know what are
your thoughts on that and then obviously
the second part what attic alluded to
about Starfield having its own show
uh I think I'm kind of like with your
with your boy Maddie here where it's
like it's interesting to see how they
miss the opportunity for game awards uh
because Maddie said and I also agree
with saying that they had a missed
opportunity to hit the wider gaming
audience uh because like you know again
and we saw we saw Jeff key to come up
with the numbers you know like like
mind-blowing like audience numbers uh
that was that's a captive audience that
Xbox Miss and like it's probably it's
surprising that with even within the
last two months they couldn't even show
up for that yeah you know but but they
can show up for for this later on like
something's going on you know um
and yeah it's disappointing that
Starfield is is still being pushed off
you know and and Xbox himself set that
expectation back in June back in June by
saying like like you know these are
going to be within the year we didn't
ask for that we didn't ask I agree I
didn't like the 12-month format I'm
sorry earlier no no no no I'm with you
that that nobody really asked for that
and like you know like like and and I
appreciate like the the intent of it you
know because like you know nobody
appreciated seeing Fable like or like as
a Nintendo fan nobody appreciates seeing
Metroid Prime 4 like four or five years
ago I've still got nothing on that too
yeah yeah to tell the truth from Shane
the devil sir
Microsoft held the difference let me
address the chat real quick first off
thinker sitting there saying you're mad
annoying hold that time out you can be
in timeout
I want them to get more time in what way
shape or form do you think doing one
cannot do the other you could easily do
both do you think that because that one
trailer is at a show everyone is not
working on Starfield stop it man I'm
going back to my grave
continue geez yeah we got the red off
again
uh yeah I don't know I I I don't know
what what Xbox can do to to to Market it
though I'm not uh you know I have no
experience in marketing video games
worldwide uh but like man like just to
what that commenter said it would be
nice is to have that kind of energy
because you know what I do think about
it are you like last last week you guys
said that this is the biggest exclusive
for Xbox since the first Halo and I was
like well maybe gears but when you
really think about it not really gears
uh it it it really is it really it goes
back to Halo one I think
I think that is true because this is
this is this is for game pass this is
the argument for this argument for game
this is the argument for Xboxes like
business future you know and Starfield
is the centerpiece of that argument yes
you know so it needs to it needs to get
out there it needs especially you know
yeah it needs to get our game bags it
needs to be clean it needs to be a clean
game yeah you can't it can't be like
what it does it used to be before you
know
it's got to be 1080. it's got to be 60
frames
at least at 1080p at least at 1080p you
know question if it is if there is no
performance mode
I wouldn't care I'd be fine with it okay
because because I wanted a few people
who look look I grew up on Xbox 360 like
we were playing games like 20 to 20
frames per second day you know so it's
like I'm okay with that like like I'm
I'm I'm I'm acclimated to all that you
know uh it's about 60 frames I'm on PC
yeah yeah you're on PC and we're never
going to hear the end of it if it is in
60 frames we're never gonna hear the end
of it everyone's gonna be good to be
complaining about it you know you know
the Sony Fanboys aren't ever going to
let up on it they're gonna be relentless
I mean they can't really be upset
because a lot of the games is 30 frames
per second anyways a kid yeah I think my
mindset is like
the fact that it's been so extra with
Microsoft about performance modes that's
an L if their Flagship game for this
year doesn't have to perform at smoke
yeah it'll be interesting a lot of
systems we'll see what happened no but I
I hear you in reference to you know what
you said in you know as far as setting
the expectation with the game awards
right and and being the fact that they
utilized that platform before to
Showcase things so they're not there but
to your point I think you know having
making this announcement I guess my
question to you is do you think they set
the proper expectation with announcing
the developer direct and seeing now hey
look Starfield we're going to dedicate
its own show do you think that was the
right approach
with that information put out
I think if they really don't have the
information for stuff already then they
got to do that they have to do that you
know it was you know but the way I see
it is damage control ahead of ahead of
it you know okay yeah because they had
to do that yeah for me it is objectively
damage control like like preemptive
damage control okay that sucks again
yeah imagine if we waited for that Gene
and Starfield wasn't there and they
didn't say it wasn't going to be oh I
was here those are my boss so I was
literally gonna say yeah they would have
been held to pay if they did that for
sure yeah like like like I would write
at the Capitol I would go I would go
you're gonna storm the Xbox offices
[Laughter]
well it does that because because
Bethesda is right up the street
we try get G locked up there
I'm okay with
it not being there because they are
going to give me such a big deep dive
but it's like at the same time it's like
dude like you guys when they came out
and jumped the gun and said 12 months
and then like I'm sitting here looking
at the at the calendar and it's just
like yo it don't look like this is 12
months even though this could easily
come out in 12 months but it doesn't
it's just I wish they never would have
said that 12 months thing yeah because I
would like that I wouldn't be surprised
I kind of like a lot of Kool-Aid here's
the thing though I said I wouldn't even
mind if Starfield got pushed back off
that June day I don't know it's just my
my thing is I forgot I just don't want
it if they do another 12-month thing
this year I don't want them showing a
game that was supposed to be in the 12
month live oh no let me tell you
something let me tell you something and
I'm Gonna Keep it 100. I'm gonna call
Gene if they missed this 12 months
gonna go down there
if it's the thing they they they gave
they pigeonholed themselves yeah they
did they did they told them they listen
this is a Todd Howard BDS open world
game in no world in nowhere it would be
to think that this game
comes out in any state
other than somewhat broke
and and it all depends on whether it's
playfully broken like oh look at this
astronaut with boobs coming out of his
head oh funny or oh
there you go or is it damn like every
time I try to boot the game up it
cracked it crashes the whole the whole
house turns off but you know the problem
the problem with this game is most most
Bethesda Games come out they're buggy at
the beginning until they get that first
couple patches done right but the fun
factor is is far surpassed the annoyance
Factor right
even even though they didn't make
Fallout 76 a sister Studio made that
game so they had to take the L for that
they have to there was nothing really in
that game so you only dealt with the
issue right so this is the thing right
to me looking back on it James said
something about how they have to be a
different Bethesda I think the one thing
that they I think they wish they would
have done
is to not even acknowledge the exist
existence of this game until
until six months for their that they
were a hundred percent sure internally
this game was ready to come out you pull
the Fallout 4 you don't acknowledge the
existence of the game I don't even care
if it is a new IP people gonna be
excited about it no matter what it's a
new bgs game now to addicts point they
had the stumble of oh we have to answer
for 76 right we have to answer for 76 so
the next thing we come out
we have to talk about it because hey we
have to make sure people are confident
in what we're bringing to the table we
did that to ourselves
my thing is if look at all the
conversations we're having it better be
60. it Well it can't if it if it this
this hypothetical window that they
created for themselves which is an
unnecessary rake right
we're all arguing about how much of
vanilla it is if it goes past the 30th
of June or whatever it does what happens
if they never said anything about this
and then at E3 they're like you'll be
playing the uh the next BTS game in
November okay King King ones that they
come out and you know like you're being
told behind closed doors
hold up hold up yeah yeah okay so you so
NDA dude you're being told you're being
told yo
it's up to you King do I release this in
May right now 30 frames a driver release
it in July 60 frames
you missed that date I'm coming for your
forehead
again when I say this isn't it
you're gonna get the full me pause but
uh after this yeah
when I say they put that's exactly what
I mean you put yourself in a position to
fail the consumer unnecessarily right
in a lot in so many ways to me I'll be
honest I don't I like I like being
surprised by stuffing by games like I
like being coming and coming into a year
and be like I don't know what's going to
come out yeah we have ideas of the only
person on the panel that I'll find some
juicy stuff out man stuff that no one
else sounds like don't tell them don't
tell them I don't want to know I love
the secrecy around games because it
makes so what we will we do reactions
songs is genuine
nothing I know nothing and that's what
my track record
I've had people literally I've had
people literally message me an entire
show right before the show before like
it's ridiculous like and I would be I
would curse that person out they did
that to me you know how it is like when
you open a message and you start reading
before you realize what you're reading
it's too late
so my thing my whole thing is this I I
like I like the I like the fact that
they're saying hey we're gonna come out
we're gonna give you deep Dives in these
games all right
I do think 40 minutes
40 minutes without star film don't
forget the extra three 43 yeah so it
really is and then you have then you
have the eldest girls online uh extended
thing right afterwards right which is
which is interesting I felt like they
should have gave that to the Video Game
Awards like right that's probably
something they could have easily put it
there and they it would have got because
I think they should have read the video
thing but it does feel like that
whatever the eso stuff is is very
substantial or substantial yeah they
even have a show after right that right
the extended thing so my thing is that
Starfield Starfield does deserve its own
thing I I don't necessarily agree that
by saying that it's it's it's coming
afterwards it's an indicator that the
game is going to miss that that
hypothetical window they created for
themselves
um because again I just to me the moment
you gave yourself the opening to move
the game to 2023 it should have always
been 11 11 23. I don't understand why
you don't give yourself
what I'm saying is though if they tell
you if Todd Howard's like you know what
it's still too broken to come out in
this in this window
s
calm it down you ain't shipping that
dick buddy not on what I'm saying I
don't want to hear I don't want to hear
complaints from King that it's it's
something
because this game is coming out in June
so you ain't gonna hear no complaints
from me now okay I'm sick and tired of
you Xbox dude
this smoke is definitely for you Xbox
dude that are too soft and too scared to
take it afraid all right yeah oh um I
want y'all to do uh uh I want to know
what's the road map they gave you a road
map they gave you 12 months of road map
right so you're sitting there like we
don't like the road map because the road
map is not good for us wait a second you
want it this way and you want it that
way they told you that stuff they said
give us like four months right because I
remember the joint well okay NDA do crap
um
it's in some polishing phase right so
they gave you longer than four months
and you still complaining it's gonna
come up all right so okay they said
they're gonna give you a show the attic
literally said I'm sick and tired of you
showing your stuff at the game awards
use your own damn platform fill with
this sadness and we're showing you a
damn thing and he was all Natty
a damn thing and you're saying why the
hell is Phil sitting there smiling and
he ain't got no game up there he said
because I'm doing my own damn show in
January so January coming and he shows
you why do Microsoft have to tell y'all
what's going to be at the show I'm so
sick and tired of Sony don't Nintendo
don't you just show up and you get what
you're doing right and and if they walk
off the show and don't show you God of
War y'all said they'd be like maybe next
time
right but they told you ahead of time yo
don't even come here looking for
Starfield that's on a separate show
later on y'all not happy with that um
they never said
a broken game that no matter when they
ship it's gonna be broken why it ain't
it cause it's broken and you gotta wait
for the other show
y'all can't have it both ways
and I want you to stand on your chest
right have some Faith Microsoft told you
by June
June
and we're gonna get another 12 months of
Christmas relax all right another 12
months of good games coming so right now
you're gonna watch Red four because
they're pushing red four right now
you're gonna watch Minecraft you're
gonna watch Forza you're getting those
three games first before star film star
Phil is bringing up the rear like Barry
Bonds and he's gonna knock it out and he
ain't gonna be broken so stop being
afraid and just sit there this ain't
soft talk Sundays
every time every time somebody loves to
get their neck out first they die
you know what I die so you can live
that's fine that's fine but let's just
remember Leonidas walked in walked into
that little that little alcove
the craziest thing is they know exactly
who he is and they know his story your
story will never be told because you
took you're sitting here
go tell my story tell them how I stood
on this and I stand on this right now so
it failed so to stop you'll have to die
for something else you know why you know
why they have to be able to succeed you
have to have faith right I got faith he
hasn't proven me wrong yet who is that
he said when when Phil told you he's not
going to ship a broken game if it's not
ready he don't care he did it with Halo
it was millions of marketing but he did
it with Halo yeah but you know what it
was better than shipping that broken
game in the state wait a minute this
goat this flies in the face of
everything you're defending you're about
to say you're about you're going to give
him the smoke if they don't meet that
June because he said you know listen
listen let's go you don't tell me
you don't tell me here pay this for this
game pass this is gonna be this this is
gonna be that we thought that Starfield
and red Falls coming out this year I'm
paying Game Pass I didn't back off all
for that you said 12 months right so I'm
gonna sit here with this 12 months that
you said I'm living up to my commitment
my commitment is support and being a
consumer live up to your consent your
commitment on delivering on your
promises like you said right so your
promises like you said is 12 months
right 12 months hanging up I'm not
bothering you Tick Tock buddy Tick Tock
okay because that June come in and you
didn't fly right I don't care if red
fall hit I don't care if falls are hit I
don't care if Minecraft hit if that star
field ain't out you are mine
12 months I'm here I hope you did too
and without what I'm saying is I think
if hindsight is 20 20 they're like we we
do not we should have never said
anything about this damn game ever ever
before I get my bars off I need to do
you sound like he was ready to jump in
that's gonna make sure he had any
thoughts or he just listened to us go
crazy but I think I think my biggest
question with Starfield is what kind of
Bethesda game are we gonna get you know
it's like we were we were talking
earlier about how in Oblivion and Skyrim
you can like pick up anything you can
pick up really really like every little
thing like like on a desk right right I
I have a hard time like seeing a game
like that running at 60 frames you know
like complexities okay so are they gonna
peel some of that back where it's like
you know like like do you really need to
pick up everything in Starfield you know
I don't know you know like like what
what kind of Bethesda game are we gonna
get you know because like
God you look at her you know like like
you look at Horizon forbidden West and
like that is a gorgeous game that runs
at 60 frames per second you know and and
like that kind of It kind of reminds me
of like a like a Bethesda game except
that you can't really just pick up
everything like yeah it's more it's more
of an action game right so it's like
when I look at Starfield I'm like okay
that this kind of looks like that kind
of game where you can have conversations
and the conversations and the action are
to set a piece of it and not so much
like oh am I gonna steal this space to
space food you know like like if stuff
like that necessary I don't know you
know
no I mean it's a good question right
based on their history and the scope of
their games you know how you know
extensive is it going to be in that
regard and I'll jump in this is fun
um how would it just just to comment on
that yeah they roll back on that
the the Maddie Maddie's not gonna be
happy I mean the the the dgs faithful if
they roll back on that level of
interaction
there's going to be a conversation all
right let me flip yeah because because
we're still talking about Fallout 4 and
how they roll back so many like
composition pieces and everything too
good for it no very good people really
have dialogue trees much in that game
that I think that they start off with a
very good start is no voice protagonist
right because I actually like that where
it's just like me too yeah I can in my
mind this is who I wanted to be and when
you kind of pigeonhole into a voice and
I think that was one of the major
mistakes I was you know the reason why
people don't receive Fallout 4 as well
as three and then a lot of the to your
point Gene the peeling back of the
systems right and it's not as you know
in-depth is um as three was but look you
know first let's talk about the direct
you know I thought they did a fantastic
job setting the proper expectation you
know for me personally I feel like you
have first of all Jade is 100 right I
was completely upset that they did not
show at the game awards I think that was
a missed opportunity I said before at
nauseam they they set the expectation by
being at the game awards they showed the
series X at the game awards they showed
hellblade at the game award they showed
Perfect Dark at that game award so Dave
they've opened himself up to an audience
that is not familiar with the Xbox brand
and has the most eyes right they didn't
show up today I thought that was a
mistake now it's cost correction
they come out with a tweet after the
game was hey we've got something cooking
for you guys soon okay cool now green
comes out with a tweet hey we're gonna
have a show developer direct I like the
name you understand develop a direct
developer focus seems to be less
personality focused which is one of my
issues with inside Xbox just show me the
games from the devs let's get to it love
that
um obviously red four is going to be big
for them I know people hating on
Minecraft's a huge game I hate that I
hate to break it to y'all but Minecraft
is uh Minecraft's the biggest game there
it's the biggest game going like I I
know people that that's what it is Forza
is going to be there very interested and
no one's talking a lot about Forza Forza
to me
is going to tell me a lot about this
release Cadence
because if we get according to the
German
um XBox uh direct developer direct
information on the German Xbox site they
said release dates so that to me now
you're setting the expectation Forza is
going to let us know okay where does
that fall the rumors allegedly with
redfall is made right this just forced
to come before that right where does it
fall in that pocket then you got the
Minecraft Legend and then surprisingly I
didn't expect to see Elder Scrolls
online so I thought that was interesting
and then you know to the point where
we're gonna get a new chapter and then
we do know who's intermax is working on
another MMO slash you know live sort of
type IP does that get revealed you know
I'm curious but I think the expectation
was right and of course redfold is huge
this is Arcane this is a huge deal this
is Co-op this is in a different space
for them you know I know some people
have concerns but I'm starting to hear
like like you saw like people cut them
more low-key excited for redfall I got a
shout out Maddie now yeah Maddie I love
you man but you sounded like the old man
yelling at the club
he don't he don't he he's he could only
do immersive Sim in a small controlled
environment no
Far Cry two and three uh Zelda breath of
the wild it can be done and Arcane shout
out to ready I understand it's concerned
I understand for the person who loves
the studio for specific things and when
you start to see them alter a little bit
yeah but what I tried to say is the bag
and how now they critically acclaimed
for like death Loop and all this new
stuff there's a whole new audience and
he's holding the door it's like it's
like a hip-hop but we just want people
to sound like rock Campbell all day yeah
I feel you but yo you know people like
guys
that's what it is so I get where he at
so let's get to the main event
Starfield situation very interesting
first of all salute to them because the
attic is so right if they would not have
said that
we showed up to the develop direct watch
the whole 43 minutes of developing the
wreck and then the next one
bro but wait
there's no more there would have been
hell to pay you know what I'm saying so
salute to them getting in front of that
I love the fact that star feels good to
get deep dive you need to give God
Howard the proper time I want to know
about all the systems the dialogue the
faction I want to see the gun play I
want to see some of them um procedurally
generated planets I want to see a lot of
this future Tech that's so ambitious I
want to know so yes give them their date
I love it and I need to see God how it
come out with a jacket that's just me
but anyway I need the brown leather I
need that I like that's what I know it's
official it's real anyway back on points
now
question that addicts talk about is
interesting I gotta be real king last
week I thought about it some more
and even though the official page
says
first half Starfield police
the only question I have is
where in the hell do you fit it if it's
first half
because here's the thing all right let's
just say May
is what you call it um Red Fort
Minecraft Legends got to get a date what
love is that
Forza gotta get a date what month is
that I think Falls is out first you take
fours just first you think is probably
in February so you're gonna say let's
say March right so we have that then the
direct for Star field in March okay so
did you say Starfield April like oh
is in June
I think we still stay the whole in June
you think it's June post E3 I think no I
think do you think 43. I think it's okay
let me explain why I think it's before
E3 break it down
these are the only people that still
holding tradition right I mean Nintendo
shows up to E3 uh Sony just you know
they figure that they're gonna sell
anyway so why waste money uh singing to
the choir right Microsoft is still
trying to gain ground how do you nullify
what anybody does during E3
put out Starfield control the narrative
do you hit him with the guard how it
come out on stage and right now you'll
be playing it like we're doing one of
those well what what I think is we doing
on that on that uh Starfield direct you
get a date
I think he you know you you have to put
the Line in the Sand
right you give them a date because
anytime a company puts out a date
that's a direct line to whoever right
it's your gangster I know yeah when Sony
put out the the date for uh God of War
it's like I dare you put your stuff over
there
um
put out breath of the wild date they
said I dare you I know what you got
coming dare you come close to this day
right so now you're up to that as a
company you have to strategize right you
already seen the first opening Salvo for
whoever it is I think Microsoft can put
it that week
just to gain the Mind share okay it's
going to sell no matter what right but
how you nullify whatever big
announcement somebody else's does is by
having actual product in hand
so they have product that they're
playing and you're talking about
something in the future like yeah we'll
get to that but right now though this is
on this so June 43 or after E3 I say
before three E3 to take away whatever
Thunder preemptively like June like the
fourth or 5th or something like that but
it's what they call Diablo
[Music]
yeah if you don't own them if you don't
own them right now you can't cannibalize
something at that pace I think Diablo's
gonna do what Diablo's going to do right
I know but you can do at probably at the
end of the month probably in the
beginning of the month I don't know how
flexible you are with it if you don't
know
I was like I will say this so there's a
big success story of A game coming out
and and that that's Last of Us Last of
Us came out 2013 went week of the week
leading up to E3 see and so again if if
you have have that level of game right
then yes because all of a sudden people
like damn okay we've seen all this new
hot stuff and that's amazing but we got
this we got this 10 right here waiting
for us and it does something because
Again Last of Us it could have easily
gone right going into the conferences
too yeah for the level of quality of
stuff you're gonna show because like hey
look everybody questioned us look at
this the biggest game that we have
coming out we we hit the nail on the
head we got it done so it gives people a
a reason to be excited for what's coming
right now it could backfire if you're
trying to do that in the game is a seven
then you know but uh if you hit that
last of us level of hype going into an
E3 but yeah I can see it but if if it's
what king is talking about so that means
you're gonna show it to your shows and
everything on the floor Starfield but
but here's the thing like they literally
said they're gonna do a standalone show
right means a separate show okay you
talk
and then you're gonna show it again at
E3 then no no no they don't show it they
said that they're gonna show it at that
event and playing it is going to carry
into yeah and then release at the end
that's where we go yeah okay I just want
to see what your body
will come out before E3
okay I don't know
how they feel about Diablo at Diablo
though man
like that like where can you like
strategically place that with Diablo
popping out on the 6th of June yeah I
don't know because if if you pop it out
at the beginning then it's just gonna
Diablo might take its shine away if
Diablo's good yeah and Diablo will be
good yeah we're gonna see I mean it's
interesting I think that's the the
interesting part about the separate show
but I will agree with myself before I go
before I give it to you is that look God
Howard don't listen to King Dave
do not listen to this but do not worry
about trying to prove or be tough
you know you gangster you ain't got
nothing to prove soft talk
they have to fight another day
don't listen to the software lineup
gangsters
right here folded in these streets
all they want to do is put they just
want to play list games they want to put
they bars
look at all the games we got the first
half bro
here's where I think here's where I
think these games are coming out okay
they don't even let me finish my boss
can I get my boss
do not listen to software lineup
gangsters right you drop it when it's
ready if it's out of the first house
This Record he gonna be over it because
when they come out whenever they come
out in the second half or whatever it's
gonna come out broken imma roast you
hard
so I come out in June oh okay one
whooping just take one whoa good January
February March April May June all right
so I think
obviously nothing in January do you
think they long do you think they launch
uh Minecraft or Forza in February I
don't know like a couple of weeks here's
the thing though
I feel like
if you a month of marketing for this is
crazy
for Minecraft is good two months
marketing for Forza is better so that
means you'll have Minecraft come out in
like February late February yeah
and then Forza comes out in April and
then you have uh redfall coming out in
May the Starfield coming out in either
June or July no no no
would you be upset if Starfield came out
like the first week of July
I'd be okay with that I'd be I I it's
kind of weird though because it's like
what what kind of difference could you
make in a week right all right and then
what was it Todd saying that they would
have just they were probably just gonna
release Starfield last year like like
imagine if Bethesda didn't have like the
Microsoft like you know like like
Watchdog over them you know and it's
like but like Todd would have just
released the game last year
[Laughter]
look at him like Todd you realize that
like you're going through the floor here
oh that's fine we'll fix that let's go
let's go worst case scenario with G so
Gee let's this is the part that the king
he calls this soft talk Sundays when we
get he says we get scared by saying how
dare you even think about pushing that
release past the first half right what's
your thought if if we get into a
potential situation where it's past the
first half maybe
later in the second half
what is your thoughts process on
Starfield releasing in that window
I don't even know what to say
he's gonna turn that fraud alert on in a
second
I mean I'd be kind of upset because you
know like like like like we like we need
this for the first half of the year you
know like like you just scared our
guests into submission
way before I said anything I mean I
would I would be upset because the Xbox
has been dry man like you know
I use the Xbox a lot for I play all my
third party games on Xbox so here we go
but we're under the impression Gene
before June you're you're getting almost
game every month
gee you go get fours you go get
Minecraft ladies hey look Halo Halo Halo
Infinite season three two you know yeah
I'm okay with it if it does get pushed
back past that 12 I'll I'll be annoyed
but I'll be okay with it as long as they
don't show that damn game again at E3
because I don't want to see it
you know why
12 months
for six of those 12 months you ain't get
a damn thing
where is that though so we're in the
next year
I don't care about you need an extra
month because you took six months from
me and delivered me nothing now for
these last six months I want nothing but
hits baby I want one for everybody
but you know what we have uh what what
is that monster hunter uh rise in
January
we don't care about the health of the
game so you can have your gangster
listen I got it we don't care about the
game you you need to have balls for the
PlayStation
shot chat put a one in the chat I can't
believe if you believe King and Gene and
put a two in the chat if you roll them
in the chat
two in the chat for the rest of the Lord
let me hear gangster list Sunday okay
let's go Forza uh with the show uh May
redfall and then in June you come out
with Starfield and you fulfilled your 12
months of what you said you were
supposed to do all right so I don't care
about that you don't care about the hell
for the game got it well the health of
the game is fine we already know that
Todd said it was good to go last year
and Phil said put it in the Baker and
we're gonna bring this bread out a
little bit later across to where we want
to release it but children if they don't
come out in the first half you gotta go
buy it
my money's in the bank already
taking my money but they haven't been
delivering okay okay but but all the
four or five games in the first half
mean actually I don't care about that
give me my give me what I said you said
you was gonna give it to me give it to
me please pause
so wait so if any of those other two
games don't make it in the six month
window you're not gonna be mad what are
you talking about this guy here for
whatever reason
if it happens not to make it you don't
care so what they said every game in
this show is gonna be 12 months right
right let something slip
that's something forget about game
development King needs his letter he
needs to get his balls stalker doesn't
make it or replace some second party
release your broken products no CC
you don't remember your months of misery
Gene is the only person here that said
we've been dry yeah I have Papa biscuits
since you told me 12 months
so you told me it was supposed to come
out and um in November all right my
throat dries
Popeyes biscuits with water they give
you the chicken they give you the spicy
chicken they give you Burgers
why biscuits this time I didn't forget
it's okay but here's here's the thing
you you want them to give you
undercooked
to cook meat
chicken my chicken gonna be cooked fine
you trying to make it comes out in July
you know what you can't have it both
ways dudes okay you can't sit there and
cry and say we dry as hell while the
competition I'd never cry y'all was
crying I told them that this game got to
be delayed I'm gonna cry the competition
can to bring out games and I don't care
if they the competition all got delayed
the competition all got delayed
off too everybody acting like this is
only an Xbox problem with like nobody
even know what Zelda fears of the
Kingdom
of the bad times every game from
PlayStation's list from the first party
is a delayed game that they did not
reach their delay you're right so why is
that I understand I should say why and
I'm gonna tell you I understand the Xbox
first party situation
I don't want a temporary issue I want it
fixed so I get it all I'm saying is to
your point Kingwood this is where you're
right
they this is self-inflicted thank you
and you are right that's what you always
in the sense that
11 11. you said it was coming out
now it's not coming out then you do a
show E3 right and then you say
everything you see here is for the next
12 months right so you now self-impose
inflicted on yourself that Starfield
comes out between that time and this
time it's E3 I get you
all I'm saying is like we said earlier
this is literally the most important new
IP in Xbox history if you botched this
game you could be out of here because
this is one of the major drivers to your
service so my point is let's not do the
list game Gamers will get over it
because the same way game is Ragnarok
hit you with the we're sorry to inform
you but we mean a little bit more time
the tweak on go out yeah I'm sorry to
inform you people gonna be mad in the
month no doubt they're going to get the
smoke rightfully so King no doubt but
when the game comes out and God forbid
it's a 90 Metacritic game is gonna
forget that game is gonna get over my
thing is I'd rather a tweet I'd rather
tweets God saying how good how well
polished the game is and tweets that's
going out to say this should have been
delayed bro if I see Craig face look at
King he's got his hand okay I've talked
I've talked I understand right
um
since this is soft toxic
I'm just watching and I was listening
um no matter what it broken anywhere
right
Sovereign
says you have to build credibility and
if you do not build credibility and
established loyalty you are expendable
so you said June
someone said is this your business
this is this is all biscuits that I was
eating
so I'm talking Sunday because
it's soft talk Sunday because I'll have
a pop-out biscuit and the first party
been so dry your voice is that weird I'm
waiting for the game sir what is your
fault you only went to Popeyes I was
eating good everywhere else
you're the one that said oh Popeyes is
it and that's it
that's a new problem
do not watch my pockets that is a you
problem if you go to Church's Chicken
they have nice honey covered biscuits
for you thank you
need some milk
[Laughter]
all right we got we got to uh get this
going on so uh we got guancus five
dollar Super Chat request for the new
showcase Cadence this is what they want
month one quarterly General preview
month two quarterly Game Pass preview
month three premiere Game showcase
what's the Cadence that he wants it
looks silly geek set King needs to start
a soft talk Sunday podcast
then we have the Don cjg with the nine
pound super chat it takes devs a long
time to get a 10 minute build together
for a show that is true a 40-minute
Starfield show is going to take a while
to put together don't show me your build
yes
all right show the belt no
yeah you get to the point where you just
got you need to show the game proper if
you're making builds that's tough
because then you have to put dedicate
extra work today we have called weeb ten
dollars of a chat King is spitting I'm
sick of Xbox having to go above and
beyond PS said nothing about God of War
until September that's fine no gameplay
a date for Spider-Man is fine but uh but
uh Starkville needs six months of
marketing
thank you thank you sir
here we have Stewie uh 108 I think 108
10 what's that Todd Howard comes out
into brown leather jacket
Power Hour comes out in the members only
jacket delay that's okay can't want to
come out for the first six months
if you come out with that members only
it's a bad look I need the brownies
all right so I didn't give me take a
look after that last one that I read
just to make sure I didn't miss anything
because the next one I have Stewie 108
and then the next one I'm gonna read
straight from the chat is Alvin so if I
miss anything between Stewie 108 and
Alvin please my apologies it's not
letting me scroll back I was too busy
arguing yeah
let's Super Chat this idea that 91
months of death for a May release equals
broken game but 93 months of debt for a
July release equals glorious Masterpiece
is odd folks have Phantom concerns for
ifs 94 meta before E3 watch so you
talking about we have Phantom
conservatives for ifs but you're already
saying it's a 94 metacrit
which one is it which one is it like and
this is very particular to these games
these games have so many systems on top
of systems things that they have to
account for the vastness of the world
it's hard to test for all of that and be
sure that nothing's broken in there
that's just difficult just to clarify
you said the last one you wrote was
Alvin and who I read Alvin right from
the chat the one before that was Stewie
108 so I just said anything in between
just one all right so tenkinesis with
the five dollar super shot March is
Minecraft ghostwire April star filled
April for Star oh we got made for red
fall June for Forza and the eso
expansion plus there are third-party
releases for Game Pass yeah yeah we
forget about whoa long and all that
other stuff
we got our kids move remember for 31
months Lord bronze we have January uh
Age of Empires two Definitive Edition uh
Feb Game Pass February Game Pass bangers
atomic heart uh marches roll long uh GP
and ghost wire Tokyo April's Minecraft
Legends made red fall Forza June star
field okay we'll see we'll see
five dollar stupid chat Starfield in
June is fine release around ff16 yes I
ran was uh concurs move Diablo till
later in the year eliminating the crunch
yeah I like it it depends on the
Activision schedule the blizzard
schedule is going to move it right yeah
then we have the ever born Saga five
dollar super channel the only way
Microsoft can get away with the
Starfield delay is if they can close ABK
in time to have Diablo 4 in Game Pass
otherwise they will be hell to pay
you're already starting with the
gangster lists
they will be held to pay until like like
our friends said that 94 Metacritic
comes out yeah that is all very it's all
good now imagine if I got delayed and it
didn't get that oh yeah
uh what is it a delayed game is
eventually good unless it's Starfield
yeah
THX 1138 two dollars we chat King leave
the gun take the cannoli
salute then we have hold on
King with Starfield is like my precious
why are people forgetting about Forza
people eight people eight sleeping yeah
nobody's forget about foreign Cooper
Texas Chainsaw Massacre is in March on
Gamepad yeah that was gonna be good to
him
shout out to King and Spartans in the
chat 2023 Xbox will Molly [ __ ] the
competition hashtag gangster list
I got the OG's out here
[Laughter]
I guess my thing is I'm such a huge but
that's the fan I just wanted to come out
in the best possible Stadium this guy's
getting delayed It's gotta get delayed
and that's it yeah exactly it's funny
you say that car because it reminded me
of what about first E3 shirts yeah the
list on the background
and say it on camera so if y'all want to
go back and check that that's it uh your
website go check it out King has lost
before
and when I win I win big King's about to
lose again where's my knees with this
Spider-Man oh we talking these talk stop
it listen I'm not doing that the gene
let's go let me get let me get these let
me take it let's move on moose is August
this remember for 15 months love the
energy TTS that Xbox needs to deliver
this year King went full smega I
couldn't even come back
see will be you two dollars Super Chat
Rockstar Games versus Bethesda who wins
this gen
then we got Master clowns X3 member for
23 months salute to the Lords you know
you already know we caught up yes sir
all right fine so to stop against
Virginia Last of Us Lord G man salute to
your excellent coverage you know what I
mean at the Washington Post you had the
legendary Neil druckman on and you also
were talking about the uh the HBO show
man so obviously
um no spoilers because we haven't
watched it yet but you know shout out to
your article you know there were some
key points that I thought really
resonated for those like I said who
haven't watched it yet because I believe
it dropped today right today is the
drops tonight tonight yeah yeah so it
drops tonight you know just what are
your thoughts you know about it I know
you can kind of briefly talk about stuff
that you wrote in your article for
people who either familiar with the
series or people who are completely new
like what what should feel
so I actually watched the entire season
so I'm like nine weeks advance of like
everyone else would be wow crazy you
know uh and some reviewers they only got
the first four episodes but I had all
nine episodes
I seen it all the way to the end
um
for people who don't know uh well you
know it's the last of us to hit
PlayStation 3 video game from 2013.
um and this show is pretty much like
really really similar to the game like
like like like like I I like I almost
said but like I'll say it right now I
think this is the most faithful video
game adaptation like like ever made like
because they wow like it's the same it's
the same lines from the game that's in
the show
like like
maybe maybe they might tweak a few words
or like an article here or there or like
maybe the circumstances of the lines
might be a little bit different but like
they are saying the same lines like
every single scene that you think is
your favorite The Last of Us they do it
they do it exactly the same way in the
show exactly in the same way
so like no spoilers but like that's a
spoiler right there it's like if you
like the scene from the show from the
game it's going to be in the show and
then and they do it exactly the same way
at Pedro Pascal and and Bella Ramsey
Bella Bella does great job is Ellie like
a lot of people are like like like
throwing shade on her but I think she
does a fantastic job she does a really
really good job of balancing like being
like adorable young but also annoying
and just kind of like like a dumb kid
too like like she she does she does a
good job being like a dumbass kid where
it's like it's like like really like
like if you want to embody Joel you're
like like shut the [ __ ] up kid
you know language sorry yeah you're good
you're good so
um yeah it's it's it's it's I'm going to
be interested to see because this is
like what people have been asking for
this is what Gamers have been asking for
for decades give me a a show or a movie
that is exactly the same as the game
like we heard we just got through Halo
in the past year you know so
good like you know like like Halo had so
many different changes and like you know
like like
what people just wanted was like just
adapt the story man just adapt the story
this is what that show did so I'm gonna
I'm I'm so interested to see one what
the what the reaction from the from the
from the gamers are gonna be like yes
you know it's like oh it's like oh this
is exactly what we wanted you know like
Resident Evil fans have been wanting
that for for years
never got it for every single piece of
it like the Netflix show the movies like
like every single Netflix show was the
worst by far it was like like it was a
horrible show but they're like I liked
it because it was funny as hell
yeah my you know you got that girl like
doing The Tick Tock dance
my question to you is with them because
you said that it was very genuine all
off the off the game so my question to
you is like with the making changes like
taking spores out of the game
um you know a lot of people have a lot
of issues of certain castings like do
you think that took away from your
experience with watching it or do you
think that you know by the time you
finish it you forgot they even took
those things out that's a great question
you know what what I was watching the
show I didn't even realize that they
took the spores out like that wasn't
even something that I was even really
paying attention to uh and it's because
they did the characters so well right
they did the characters so well that
you're not even thinking about like oh
there's no sports section of the game
here and you get that because like you
know like and Neil said that in my
interview he says people are a little
bit wiser to the pandemic so it's like
when you think about how the sports will
travel into your mess like Joel would
have gotten affected within like the
first like three hours of the game
considering considering how close he was
to the spores right so it's like so it's
interesting that they took that out I
didn't even notice it I don't think a
lot of people are I don't think people
are even going to notice it because
they're paying too much attention to how
well Pedro Pascal is portraying Joel how
he's got the voice down how the lines
are being said you know
um
you know people were were crying about
Maria tobby's brother Tommy's brother's
wife or Tommy's wife being black and
it's like you know like it doesn't
matter like Tommy's already Mexican you
know so it's like who cares you know
like right like by episode six or seven
you already know that These Guys these
guys are Hispanic so at any point in the
in the do they call him Joelle
well no they do not they do they do they
don't okay they don't do that these are
very very Southern Hispanic Southern
Latinos
yeah this is this is exciting man I
think reading your article you know the
way you mentioned how like you know like
you said most Studios sometimes they
they go away from the source material
and I like that you know this seems to
be staying true to it even down when you
said to the lines and stuff like that
and then you made a comment he was like
um but as someone who admires the
original game and what it achieve HBO's
The Last of Us are still fascinating
enjoyable ride through it old familiar
Adventure tale probably actors who are
honor the original Vision he said when
you said when I compare the two stories
and the artistic choices made to
differentiate the show from the game I
have to admit the HBO version sometimes
steals the show okay because there are
enough changes with it with certain some
of the characters you all played the
game right yeah of course of course
classic so like you know there are
changes with like you know so because
they run into a bunch of different
characters rather there's there's bill
right Evan Henry there are changes to
Bill storyline that makes it so much
better there are changes to stamina
Henry's story like where it's like you
know the beats are still the same the
same stuff happens the same stuff
happens like I say that much right but
like how Sam and Henry developed their
characters like like their storyline
their reason for wanting to leave the
city in the first place is different
from the game it's just from the game
okay because like in the in the game
they just said we just want to get out
of the city now they they actually like
explain why they're trying to get on the
scene okay backstory to that that's
really interesting you know and and so
that's what I was going to ask you like
in the in the manner that they fill in
the blanks and give you more texture for
that world and yeah do they do it like
you mentioned Bill obviously there's a
backstory to Bill that it kind of is
alluded to right and do so do they fill
in the blanks in that way they
absolutely fill in all the blanks like
like anything that you think is alluded
to like like like they just they just
filled that up in the in the show so um
you know and I will say that like like
you you read every review they're all
talking about what episode it's the bill
episode
it is the bill episode once that episode
lands like everyone's gonna be talking
about it everyone is going to be talking
about it it is so goddamn good good it
is so good do you think playing the game
and knowing the outcome took away from
any of the big moments because you kind
of kind of knew they were coming because
you play played it totally yeah totally
totally you know like like obviously the
ending would have been a complete
shocker to be I didn't play the game
right
um so I'm also super interested to see
you know like like anyone who didn't who
never watched who've never played the
game see the ending and then yeah how
they're going to feel about you know
what happens at the end you know it's
like that red wedding moment when you're
watching video of people watching the
Red Wedding you're like okay here it
comes the reaction content out of this
is gonna be so fascinating yeah I'm a
Marvel fan and you know marvel fans in
the comic books so anytime they change
anything around in the films I already
know that they have to change it around
for certain reasons right so Eric and I
talked about the sports thing and I
think the spores was put in place as a
gameplay mechanism for the game and it's
not necessary and being told in this
medium uh to progress the story so you
remove that gameplay element out and you
just tell a straight story I think we're
going to have a problem with the people
that played the video game games the you
know the gamers and the casuals the
people that didn't play it but what
Sony's deal is what they're trying to do
is broaden the horizons of of the
franchise to reach uh to cross-pollinate
to be honest with you so you have the
gamers that can watch the series because
they're fans of it and get a greater
appreciation and you have fans of the
the series that can say well it's a
video game made of this and then when
they do go play and then the spores is
in there it's it's it's like a different
element that they didn't see exactly
it's gonna be a different like like like
interesting experience of it you know
and I was actually watching the show and
playing the game at the same time
which was a weird experience because I
would like I would finish what would
happen in the in the show and I'd be
like okay let me go play that part of
the game right now and it was
interesting it was a weird like little
association thing going on in my head
where I was like I'm playing the Pedro
Pascal game right now yeah an actual
question all right so I find Neil
druckman probably one of the greatest
video game uh writers and directors of
Our Generation right I'm a huge absolute
huge fan especially after the little
last of us too did you ask him
um
when he was writing The Last of Us won
was he pinning The Last of Us two as a
complete story how far did he reach I
didn't ask that I didn't know that yeah
no yeah I'm sorry okay I'm gonna say I
think the biggest reason I want this
this to succeed is because like I'm
tired of these people taking stuff like
Halo and like mocking the people that
want it to be more on the line like it's
okay to deviate but I feel like some of
these people deviate just because they
know people are going to get upset about
it and it's just like you know look
every time people have respected the the
core material it's been a mad success
you got like I I say over and over again
I will support the Sonic movies into the
day I die because when that Abomination
saw uh Sonic came out and they could
have easily have rolled with that it
cost them a lot of money to fix that but
like you know what people are upset the
people that love this individual in the
games are upset we got to make it right
they went back they delayed the movie
and made it right and now it's just like
you look at just that it's like now it's
a mad successful they're about to make a
third one so it's just like
so you could easily do it to where it
it's everyone but it keeps the core
happy and and it annoys me when you see
people changing drastic stuff that makes
no sense to change and it's just like
but I want I want people to see a gaming
universe or see a gaming store and be
like we can make money with that and I
feel like with these directors
consistently always letting letting the
story change drastically we're not
seeing much of that because they're like
look we tried Resident Evil didn't work
out yeah because you didn't stick to
anything of the source material that's
something like Sonic that's about to do
three of them because they stuck to the
source material and and I feel like last
was that that's one of the biggest games
in existence and if they get the the
props for keeping that close to the
source material other people's like okay
maybe it's not the gamers maybe it's us
well maybe we've been stupid this entire
time trying to change the game story
when it's like we could just do do that
you just adapt the adapt and stay true
you're exactly right so I look at
cyberpunk Edge writers
use it use the music from The Game the
show so good people loved it you know
but people are hypocrites because you
say that the Resident Evil you know
didn't stick to the source material
those with highly successful movies you
know regardless to whatever material
that they did use they just used the
name recognition of Resident Evil for
the fan base to get the core inside but
the casuals drove that market and the
movies changed but it was successful so
the encounter to that argument of uh
it's not good I don't know no no that's
a good Counterpoint I mean look you know
how I feel about
but I can't deny the success right and I
can't deny that the obviously they have
a season two and people want it and I'm
curious the views on that like because
we we were going up on that as pretty
much as pretty much a joker let's watch
let's watch the the the dumpster fire
this week let's discuss it every week I
mean you know what's funny is what you
know spoiler alerts anyone in the chat
I'm about to ruin the ending
don't do that they've had forever to
watch that you don't know please don't
do that yeah we're doing it I can't
explain the point without saying dude
guys spoil it for people who have not
watched it all I will say is I
understand your your frustration I'm
with you on respecting Source material
I'm always going to be with you or
respective source which I think that's
super important to understand the the
core what why this series is below what
makes people gravitate towards it you
know and back to the last of us look
this is a fantastic job I like you know
drugs seems like his Hands-On
involvement
um I liked your interview
um right now I believe this year is the
10th anniversary of the last 10th
anniversary of the last time
insane they have a lot of big things
planned for it too so yeah yeah that's
what so like that that is that is insane
to me like just to to see the Journey of
that game just one quick question um I
don't know I know you didn't get a
chance to really talk too much about it
but they've kind of announced they show
like design aren't from factions right I
believe not that long ago so I'm just
curious like what did you think I want
to ask you to do like what do you think
we might be getting that you know
well it was interesting you know my
interview made headlines because Neil
Jackman talked about Elder ring and he
didn't talk about he talked about how
like you know like the way elderly tells
his story is really interesting and
that's what captivated so I'm wondering
if any of those lessons are going to be
applied to the multiplayer because like
you know the one concern that people
have of about alas of us like metaverse
type multiplayer is is The Last of Us
world really the kind of place that
people want to hang out you know
um and it's like it could be if you're
able to tell a good story through the
environment in there if you if if you're
if the storytelling of the environment
is good that I think a lot of people
want to want to hang out
I'm really interested to see what they
do whether they learn anything from
Bungie you know yeah that stable based
bungee uh but you know like Fashions one
was fun you know I was one of those
those few players that actually played
The Last of Us multiplayer it was great
yeah they can do it like the division
and have like a Garg Zone type of thing
and then you're going exactly yeah
I played the division like like thinking
like oh yeah this is like the last of us
yeah same universe as the last of us to
me you know yeah that'll be fine luck
man tremendous interview you killed that
van Truck Van it was great to hear I
love the quote what he said about
um you know developers one thing that
gets them to stay in it is when they're
passionate about what they do you know
what I mean and but you know can use the
exam we were lucky to have um the great
Jason Rubin on and he mentioned him and
how you know they were doing crash and
you know after a while you get burnt out
from that and then it became Jack and
Dexter and then you know being for them
to be able to to do Uncharted and then
you know last of us all these different
things creatively and to see still has
those juices I thought that was really
cool and a phenomenal interview man you
killed that and I'm really excited you
guys have Jason Rubin that's awesome
he's an icon I met him I met him too and
I was I told him like dude I love Jack
too you know like he made here he made
Jack too it was his decisions to make
Jack to like Grand Theft Auto and I was
like yes you made the right choice we
had him on and it was just phenomenal
the stories you could tell and I said
you know to see Neil druckman pay homage
to Jason and them for shedding the
foundation for that and that creativity
was was really cool to see Naughty Dog
the elections out here so salute that
you're on that I was gonna just combine
this last topic so we could just if we
don't mind ourselves so then we're doing
kind of thing yeah yeah
um Ubisoft man um let's talk about it so
this is your topic what is happening
with Ubisoft all right okay so
um yeah so like Wednesday
there was a report coming out of Ubisoft
shout out to VGC which is where I'm
getting this information
indicating that uh and I quote
Ubisoft is facing major challenges as
the industry continues to shift towards
Mega Brands and long-lasting titles that
can reach players across the globe
across platforms and business models
so it says that it's they essentially
spent the last couple of years trying to
take its biggest brands and kind of move
with the trends make these sort of
living games breathing games that allow
these games to uh you know to live for
generations and just continue to add
content a you know AKA these uh you know
these service based games and they
haven't necessarily been successful and
obviously the biggest games in there and
in their sort of uh franchise biggest
franchises that they that they have
still haven't seen the light today in
terms of those types of games right we
have the traditional games so uh yeah
they announced that they had canceled
three unannounced games as a result of
sort of trying to limit the scope of the
type of games that they're releasing
um and also that they've once again
delayed Skull and Bones you see a
thieves Keller the Sea of Thieves killer
into into uh into the the end of the
year possibly into 22 24.
um
they were supposed to drop off
Sonic by itself
to deal with creators
they had to fix his water it had hard
water thank you
so uh yeah they basically saying that
the you know the the shots that they've
taken at this type of game
have failed up front and a lot of times
to me looking at it it just feels like
they've been late to the trend uh
Ubisoft when it came to kind of
revolutionizing the open world a little
bit with Assassin's Creed 2 even one
right the things they started with one
and two they were at the cusp of it they
were at the beginning of it so they they
kind of when people say the ubisoft's
open world they're talking about
Assassin's Creed and Far Cry and stuff
like that and that's when they were at
the top of it when you hop on a trend
towards the end of it and the saturation
in the market already unless you have an
exemplary game that takes all the
mistakes of of that the games are
currently in the market of making and
fixes them and then improves upon them
you're probably not going to have a
successful product it's just what it is
and they've been late to the party in a
lot of ways right in addition to that
their standard the games that they kind
of expected to do well have not done as
well they expected Mario rabbit Sparks
of Hope to do well did not do as well as
the first game um at least to this point
right and then
exactly it's just one of those things
that for whatever reason
the excitement around it wasn't there
and then you look at a staple year in
year out
Just Dance didn't do well and Just Dance
you know this dance is still selling on
on Long dead consoles because of the
fact that this is a game that comes out
you know really whatever yeah and it
continues to sell well so um this has
kind of forced them to sort of readjust
how they're doing things moving forward
um so in in Louisville this stuff the
report that followed all of this that
basically
an email by Eve GMO hello I'm Eve Gamo I
care about indicating that you know he
told the staff like it is on you to
reverse our fortunes like basically the
things that we've been working on have
not panned out the way we wanted them to
the the games that we have in that vein
that are from our biggest franchises
aren't ready to go yet everything that
comes out from here on out is going to
determine what the future of Ubisoft is
so he kind of you know put the onus on
his workers to to
kind of you got to fix this you got to
fix this what a boss stupid
[Laughter]
so uh yeah I mean what are you guys and
then off of this right shout out to Jeff
Grove because Jeff group grub uh
reported
I don't know how much a reporter is it
was or him just making a comment but he
had indicated that they had been talk
about you know Ubisoft shopping itself
to potential buyers
and well what was funny about it is that
at this point after everything that's
happened in the position that Ubisoft is
in now in many is uh situations they
were apparently essentially laughed out
of the room
um oh
so oh I didn't know this and what's
what's funny about this is that when you
look at the stuff that's still coming
out it feels kind of feels like what
ubisoft's answer to this is well okay we
have these service based games coming
out based on our biggest franchises
that's gonna come but it's also pushed
them to be like okay we we need to go
back to our roots and kind of what what
allowed us to become this successful and
make smaller games go back to the single
player thank God Splinter cells not
canceled yet um we're getting Mirage
this year which is a smaller Assassin's
Creed game we're gonna get the avatar
game it's back to loot crates yeah go
back to that so um I want to know what
you guys think about this and this idea
that now they don't despite being in a
position you know how I always say you
know when the fox hears the rabbit
scream becomes the running but not to
help
um despite being in this weekend
position it does not seem that anybody's
willing to bite in terms of uh picking
them up
what do you guys think about all this
because it's interesting because Ubisoft
in a lot of ways kind of felt
recession-proof because they always they
at the launch of every every Hardware
despite some of their games not doing
well at when when they launched you know
we know Siege when it launched wasn't
great and then all of a sudden they
turned it into this Mega thing same with
uh what the heck was the the the weapon
combat game that's still for Honor right
for Honor which is you know it's it's
more of a niche thing than say Rainbow
Six is but it's still big in its own
right and continues to be big
um what do you guys think of all this
because this is kind of weird I think a
lot of it is attributed to the fact that
they've jumped they tried to jump on too
many Trends after the wave is is is over
and it's cost them a lot of money
and for a lot of people kind of
confidence in the type of games that
they're going to start seeing from them
so what do you guys think Luigi let's
start with you man what do you feel
about all this Ubisoft news
I think well first of all I think I'm
not I'm not surprised at all that nobody
wants to buy Ubisoft because who the
hell wants to buy a company with like
500 000 employees across India and India
and Singapore and everything like that
that sounds like an HR nightmare like
Microsoft would invite wouldn't buy that
you know that's crazy
um and they got their own scandals too
let's not forget right yeah
and they have tencent money now that's
another thing
they got all kinds of things going on
over there yeah yeah what's interesting
is that it doesn't seem to be really a
you know because Assassin's Creed about
how like like you know like like it
sucks that it has like 90 hours more
than it needs to but that's a good game
you know and Writer's Republic nobody
paid attention to that game but that
game was all right you know yeah
um so it's not it's not even a lack of
quality that Ubisoft is putting out
there something's going on within
management where they're they're just
not not putting the money where it needs
to be
um and like certain projects are not
being managed well like you got Prince
of Persia and like never coming out uh
you know
uh you know I I I heard from from my
sources that Watchdog Legion was kind of
a mess too in terms of being made uh
like like management was coming in and
out out of that too so you know yeah I
don't know I don't know what Ubisoft
does
they need they probably need to right
size their company you know because
because the fact that they're bigger
than Activision Blizzard yeah you know
that's crazy that is sorry that's crazy
like like that's just that you you over
hired and you you over invested and like
you need to like like I hate to say it
but you probably need to let some people
go you know and I shaved it off you know
because I don't understand what you're
doing with all that money you know oh
some valid points valid concerns I don't
know if he stepped away if he's still
there but um if not I'll so I'll be king
you want to jump in on uh
um I think it's uh besides the failed
projects and stuff like that is the
whole thought process and the model
behind it I think the field uh Ubisoft
plus deal thing uh is a was a huge
Arbitrage because they could have got in
on the the PlayStation bandwagon early
or Xbox game pass bandwagon early uh it
was like too late to the party and
getting that stuff there they did
promise it at a certain date and then
those dates weren't hit uh I think
fewer are not a console manufacturer
and Sony's reluctant in doing this
putting their first party titles in
their own service I think it behooves
you as a console manufacturer to do so
you must you know do so to push your
product but when you aren't a console
manufacturer and you're a third-party uh
you know distributor multi multi you
know
um platform uh distributor
you hurt yourself when you have your own
service right and your games is in your
service
nobody's purchasing it there that's not
what they know you from they know you
from being multiplayer here here and
there and then you find out later I
didn't find out until later like oh they
have a service where do I get their
service at so when it becomes convoluted
you lose that people you know people
people don't like to multi-click you can
you can see it on Tick Tock people don't
want to go to tick tock to YouTube to
Facebook it's too much I don't want to
do it right so that's that's what
happened there so they didn't get the
money from their services which was a
good service but if nobody knows how to
get to your service it's a bad service
right and then you finally put it in a
curated form in the PlayStation and in
the Xbox it's uh additive it's not a
main thing now you're looking for
purchasing the biggest problem with them
was loot crates same thing happened with
EA same thing happened with them
EA navigated it a little bit and got out
of the storm
because they have franchises that
continue to sell Madden continues to
sell no matter what every year Madden
can bring around the reoccurring dollars
that they can pull up some of the weaker
titles
Assassin's Creeds haven't been able to
do that and you're saying the dance
games haven't been able to do that and
the other titles that haven't hit they
Mark haven't been able to do that so
nobody's going to purchase them like
they said is a nightmare as far as the
employees go
what happens do they start licensing IPS
out do you go there Microsoft said
listen I do an exclusive deal for to get
the Splinter Cell bring Splinter Cell
back home over here does that happen
does a Sony go over there and say listen
that Assassin's Creed that's coming out
that you was going to put on somebody
else could we get this right they're
gonna have to start looking at those
options because nobody's looking to
purchase a mess they'll purchase pieces
of your mess but not the whole thing
Microsoft is not in the position to
purchase anybody mess because they have
their own mess going on right now so
honest attic I see you back Ubisoft
situation your thoughts
I think they'll be fine no I think one
of the biggest things that they probably
have issues with is
we always give them props for it you
know you you support a game even if two
people playing it yeah but maybe maybe
at this point it's like okay maybe for
honor it is done like you've been doing
it for this long how many people
actually realistically play in that game
yeah they I think they're supporting the
division again now aren't they so it's
like I'm sure that's resources that
could have went somewhere else it's like
you know after a certain amount of time
okay maybe maybe it's maybe it's enough
yeah it's just like Gene said they
probably have a lot of money going to
places where I shouldn't be going to
Mobile yeah yeah well I mean mobile
probably makes the money but it's it's
just do they have good mobile games
that's the point right you know it's one
of those things where it's like
you might get too comfortable in the uh
the five different types of games you
make too maybe you should you know
expand and experiment because if you
don't you're not going to have the next
pillars to run your company because
these pillows clearly are are getting to
the point where they're not supporting
your company anymore and then it's like
you know we get to it too
like Gene said maybe maybe they're
bloated maybe they need to cut down on
some of that bloat and you know run the
company effectively now how long do they
make Skull and Bones like 10 years it
feels like yeah I remember that you know
they got a lot of a lot of excess stuff
that's going on maybe if they would have
cut Skull and Bones five years ago and
made something else that that studio
could have made three games by now uh so
it is what it is yeah I I don't know I
mean I don't think Sony would ever buy
that company because it seems like to me
they trying to get someone to buy them
right so it's like there's not a lot of
Studio a lot of companies that's in the
gaming industry I mean obviously like
apple or someone or Google could pick
them up but I I just I don't see too
many people willing to come in there and
deal with all that mess they have going
on yeah it's a lot man I'll jump in
quickly um
I was I was I'm not too surprised that
there's been a decline I felt they've
been on decline even when a lot of
people wanted Microsoft to acquire them
I never felt and I'm Lord acquisition by
the way you know I've never felt they
were a good Target you know what I mean
just just I felt a lot of stuff was on a
decline to me the red flag is when I saw
a dance dance and Mario rabbits
underperformed because some you remember
like we we went to the Ubisoft uh E3
patch conference yeah and I remember
being upset G I used to go in there I'm
like damn they giving dance dance all
this pops a whole dance number on the
stage and then I saw the numbers that
danced this was doing for them and I
said oh I get it man I was wrong this is
me being hardcore gamer
until recently they were still making it
for the week yes yep yep yep I didn't
realize Yeah dance dance was that big so
now I'm saying dance dance is
underperformance Mario rabbit is the
first one at it but I was like a huge
but you got yeah
you got to think that came out around
the launch for the garage switch Yeah
that probably bloated a lot of those
cells but I was shocked because I
figured switch game would be on it
because it's America they were on it for
the beginning because there was nothing
else to play it's not really like that
anymore like there was plenty of stuff
to play today but I thought Mario would
push that through like it's a third base
game though that's a very small group
already yeah yeah I guess I see those
two uh and then you gotta look fire
emblems right around the corner right
around the corner the people that was
that was on the switch okay the Fire
Emblem the one that we actually want to
play is right around the corner so and
you have midnight Sons competing and at
the same time it was around that same
launch window too oh no yeah it was they
weren't too far away it came out of the
busy large window too like you know God
of War came out like like I have Mario
rabbits I haven't played it at all
because yeah I reviewed it but they came
out around the road
look that's that's a bad decision right
there
so um look they got that the skullar
bone situation we know at nauseam I
remember that thing was supposed to be
like a a Black Flag DLC that just
expanded and it became its own thing I
remember people were saying that was the
season killer I remember people like yo
see these it's on it's doing this is
what we want and I'm like hey this is
you know where that's at and it's a
shame because I look at Ubisoft
historically I've actually liked Ubisoft
back in the day I like split itself yeah
like Rainbow Six Siege I'm a ghost recon
dude you know what I'm saying I used to
rock with the ghost Recons that was one
of my first Xbox Live games you know
what I'm saying I was Alpha tester I
used to love myself so just to see where
they're at and the Assassin's Creed you
know but solve you're right what I knew
something was up
[Music]
is our speaker but Maddie on this one
dude whenever you see companies
preemptively give you their y'all we got
six assassin Creeds games coming we've
got this franchise like to be you
getting sexy for acquisition you try to
show how great things are for the future
you know what I said you got your
Friday's best this is what we doing and
we're gonna have for the classic
assassin Creeds guys then we're gonna
have this for the modern take and I'm
like man we like the show I I think I
think that the reason that it works for
PlayStation that PlayStation can carry
the whole Sony companies because they're
not as bloated as Ubisoft you're saying
like 30 projects going at any time it
feels like they got 30 new projects they
got 15 that's been running for 15 plus
years like like it's at this point
Assassin's Creed and Rainbow Six Siege
cannot carry the whole company and
that's the thing it's like you know the
the shots that they've taken and making
these service based games I forget I
keep forgetting the name the name of the
game game that they dropped and just
canceled almost immediately
hyperscape and then and what's the
extinction Rainbow Six Extinction right
where Extinction kind of came and went
and then you have what's the other one
gene what's the other one with the uh
yeah and that you know that is whatever
so they keep trying to again they they
come into the trends late and then it
stands out I think a lot of it is
because how much money that they invest
in those games that is down the toilet
essentially dude right do you think that
their obsession with making uh service
games is starting to run their company
into the ground because they're not
trying new things that isn't service
related yeah well like you know I said
earlier that Ubisoft hasn't had a
quality problem but they definitely have
of trying new things problem right
they're not trying anything new you know
they're they're not innovated they're
chasing chess even with Assassin's Creed
they're they're chasing The Witcher 3
Trend yes it's like it's like I'm sorry
but but like you know open world games
are you know we played Elden ring last
year I'm sorry but like like we moved on
from The Witcher 3 formula and then now
we're moving them something different
you know yeah no it's a good point good
point yeah that's pretty much all I had
I thought the last thing I thought was
interesting was the 10 cent relationship
you know I think they upped their stake
in the company again and as far as
investment and uh about to buy that
company we'll see if they can I'm
inching the money over and over again
while you guys ready now we just write
the big check back I'm not sure if they
can do a full takeover but it is
interesting I think at this point
Ubisoft just willingly sell them the
company we gotta see man we got to see
what happens but yeah right they because
there is stipulations in in how the
amount of of the company that they own
that after X amount of time they're
they're allowed to buy x amount of more
shares and so it's one of those things
again when you think about
coming out and saying hey you know
revenge is trying to take us over help
us we want to keep this company a
family-owned thing and now you know the
time's a little uh rough and the
willingness to sort of parse off your
your company a little bit you can see it
so
um yeah it's sad because because I just
think they they kind of came to these
Trends too late the products they
released aren't superior to the ones
that are already in the market people
only have so much bandwidth to to pick a
certain type of games but you know as a
destiny player you don't have a lot of
bandwidth for a lot of games that are
like that so unless you come in with a
superior product it's gonna die properly
and then we we got to be real there's
only enough bandwidth to play service
games in general like there's only so I
can only play one service game really at
a time like the moment I jump to
fortnite I pretty much threw Destiny in
the tank because it's like you can only
play one without oh man okay I gotta do
this battle pass that battle pass this
battle pass you're right those games
expect you to live in them and in them
and that's the thing so you know I I I
it's it's it's imagine the whole company
doing nothing but making those times
again you're literally cannibalizing
your own games let's see the thing is
and what what you don't realize you just
need one Fortnight you're doing fortnite
can save your company from other you
know you know the variables that have to
happen before you make a fortnight yeah
but if you can't make one if you don't
try yes well they've been good they've
been trying but again not everything is
fortnite inside the room
and Siege as much money as much money as
Siege someone get the first aid kit as
as much money makes things
standing in front of all of his
employees like it is your fault
oh it's crazy it's like equivalent to
like going up and like look we need you
guys to get us back to where we were and
then it's like the first person in the
front that talks too much gives out an
idea we're not doing that who else has I
do
he like he like the decision wasn't his
to make you know to make all these
service games
this is the time where creativity
happens when you can look over to the
crowd and say all right listen who has a
passion project that they really
passionate about
you got you got the staff that's like
help me help you you gotta see what's
gonna happen but yeah very very
interesting situation I think the
positive to it is that it seems like I'm
getting more of the games that I love
we'll go get split as well we're getting
uh an old school I think that's what's
gonna happen the biggest thing I think
they're big they need to diversify make
different types of content with the
service they they just need to stop
being 100 on the surface make Splendor
sell single player games start getting
your name back out there and then it's
like rely on a couple services to really
get your game going instead of like we
got eight games
you can only play one to two that's a
good point they were converting a lot to
live service yeah but they still have
some coming they have you know division
Heartland yeah yeah they have the mobile
the Assassin's Creed Jade
um what the heck else do they have like
I honestly feel like the division of
maybe one other game they need to focus
on those games and those games only and
just start building games around those
yeah we'll see what happens as long as I
get myself anyway
so we're gonna wrap up man long uh super
chats and then um pull and we get this
yeah hold on a second let me roll back a
little bit man we're gonna get a gene
out first before the supercharge
um yeah it's almost done no no we're
just gonna drive
I said he said he was well rested
this far
because I might need him in June I might
have to pull up
we got Daryl maximum for two years five
dollars what's that I'm changing the
narrative Iron Man VR is hella fun oh
yes it is oh yeah it is absolutely fine
I ain't played it then we have Iron Mike
five dollar Super Chat so if spores are
a plot hole in the show weren't they
always a plot hole in the game that
everyone Praises for his excellent
storytelling yeah there's a narrative
around this storytelling thing and
people saying it's the you know one of
the great you know the greatest story in
gaming and whatever and I will say this
yeah go ahead right there talk to
yourself come on let me hear it let me
get ready come out it is it is
impressive that so like Gene said the
game Translate so almost one to one to
the because of the level of Storytelling
in the game I think what people forget
about a game is that sure maybe the
story is derivative from something in
some way shape or form but at the end of
the day the agency you have in that game
to to play the character and be that
especially with a game like the last of
us where at the end the Revelation is
I'm the bad guy
I'm the bad guy and if anybody knows of
a certain uh Star Wars don't want to be
the bad guy if you keep delaying this
part listen yeah
let me Babble let me babble
there's a certain Star Wars RPG where
there's a revelation about being the bad
guy that uh yes I would say that's cool
go play that game
Dorian Gray my problem with anything
last of us is that nothing else is
allowed to be good it sucks the air out
of the room we just came off Arcane Edge
Runners near has a one for one anime and
people disrespect them that's true
nearer well we only saw one episode so
far but that what episode was one for
one so it is interesting to see near and
lots of us both come out yeah and both
of these games both of these games are
always considered the best stories ever
made yeah there's definitely a Sony bump
going on with the Last of Us
[Laughter]
I just can't wait until Sony remasters
The Last of Us TV show yo
yo that was messy
yeah
yo
now in 8k
that was messy
we heard you guys loud and clear you
loved the first one so we remaking it
again
how could you do that we have Matt
without feet on the remaster
[Laughter]
they need to form better but didn't
address the management issues and
workplace scandals so toned yes
purposefully tone deaf I would say true
I still can't get over there
again
[Laughter]
Nintendo under uh Nintendo
underperformed their management took a
pay cut yeah that's true um you'll be so
underperformed and he Guillermo says
damn that is a good point Nintendo did
do a lot for the they're gonna crash to
be destroyed let me see if we were back
a little bit we got a two dollars from
Lord Metroid Gene likes Super Metroid he
knows Perfection
you concur that's it all right all right
pole with Starfield now confirmed to get
its own Deep dive outside of the Xbox
developer direct when do you expect to
see this showcase traces are eight
before March 2023
B between April through June of 2023
see it's soft talk second half
[Laughter]
I don't care God how I better come out
with the brown leather on days salute to
the legendary Gene Park of the
Washington Post not only one of the
funnest guests that we've had in the
room rocked the entire film which I did
not expect and was absolutely amazing
brother where can the five people find
you tell them tell the rest well first
of all I just want to thank you all for
inviting me it's been a true honor I was
looking forward to this all week
honestly I was looking for unfortunately
it's like like once I knew I was like
okay I'm good feeling good I gotta tell
Carl good I'm good to go because I
really really want to go on the Lord's
so you can find me uh at
washingtonpost.com
and uh you can find out on Twitter at
Gene Park nice brother yo you are an
inspiration love the brutal honesty the
grind that the stories I mean were just
tremendous and just just it it just goes
to show you you know your journey you
know where it took you all the things
you've been through to get there was was
really just very cool to learn and like
I said just be inspirational about and I
just love your passion for gays man it's
a man love video games that's what it is
brother salute to you for repping the
culture you know and of course you know
you're welcome to come back in Cameo and
whatever you will will have you back
whatever you feel for it I'm glad we
waited because I know you were building
and I'm glad we waited to do it now you
know what I'm saying because we got the
full Gene Park experience Lord attic uh
one of us give Gene his send off and you
know just tell him what's up
yeah I appreciate you coming on man we
actually have a lot in common when it
comes to the games we play growing up
you like the the older Asian part of me
what is it Kingdom Hearts Resident Evil
and what is it Final Fantasy Final
Fantasy yeah
Kingdom Hearts I was I wasn't really
that into I still have to play Kingdom
Hearts too you know
I appreciate it that's the better one
but uh yeah I appreciate you coming on
we we had a pretty good uh we had like
what almost 800 people yeah yeah what's
up people every like button you hit we
it saves a rare animal in Afghanistan
if you hit the like button remember
save two camels
another soft voice to like that no
you're gonna use up my voice
[Laughter]
that's it though we got some changes
we're going to be making probably here
in the next week uh the first thing that
had to happen was we had to change
things over and this podcast seemed like
that was a success yeah so uh we'll
we'll go from there appreciate your help
or lancer I was definitely stressed out
my jeep was dead trying to get it right
but anyway we got it done and of course
Lord solved where can I find people find
you right now also about uh
thank you so much for coming on bro um
for me I you know again I'm always about
somebody who who likes to go against the
grain a little bit and you know the
moment you you got on the pot podcast
and then and then you
talked about about some of the stuff
behind the scenes that people were
saying to you you just you held strong
it's like there's no reason for me not
to be here and I love that because again
the community there's so many great
aspects of this community we all should
be repping there's no reason to create
the business between us it's just it and
you're a prime example of why you know
the great parts of this community
continue to shine so and obviously the
journey the personal Journey you've been
through the things that you that you've
had to deal with especially the past
year like I said you know when I when I
jumped into the chat I was like it's
just good to see you up and about yeah
and and kind of back to your old self so
thank you so much man appreciate you
coming through I I appreciate that thank
you so much for for shouting me out on
you know like what happened on Collins
show and everything you know like I I I
gotta stand on my principles you know
absolutely I I I I I I stand by by what
I believe and I stand by my action
we went through it too
we were like yeah I was like look I
guess there's not gonna be the show that
you listen to but we're gonna We want
everyone's perspective and as much as
possible as long as it's respectful and
it was great man it was great to see
people having dialogue again talking
about games and they're respectful
manner so that's that's what it's about
Lord King ready to find people find you
right now Gotta Give Gina send off man
um didn't know what to expect
right so it's like a box of chocolates
right I feel like Forest Gump and you're
going through your chocolates and you're
picking out your best
um
sir your your journey is incredible
right but better than your journey is
your mindset
and uh for you to be cancer
God bless yes Lord but your mindset is
always in a space of how can you become
indispensable how can you overcome so
you've been overcoming for a long time
so
um you know to beat it to be here
and I've always looked at the mark of a
champion right
um and I can say this like Earl Spence
was in a terrible car accident
his first fight back wasn't a tomato can
that he can walk over his first fight
back was uh taking on Danny Garcia
Top Flight champion
your first article back you said you
wanted to get in there swinging that's
what a champion does don't want no light
touches don't want no soft touches
because you know
there's another a young Gene Park
looking to take your spot
and he's looking for that weakness
and he said is this the moment and you
said hell no sit your butt down well
that's what he said absolutely love yeah
exactly all right so I truly respect
that and I thank you for being here
you're enriched my life today with your
story and your candor you sir you're
Kansas second tonight yeah they always
lit it's lit I like that so you can
catch me on RNR with the Lords with
attic uh Tuesdays at 5 p.m where we're
going to be talking The Last of Us uh
this week you will have a great time uh
attic and I is crafting something very
special and our diverse opinions on a
couple of these topics definitely have
you uh rolling in the house so uh come
and tune in and uh catch me on Twitter
where I'm uh probably gonna be ranting
and raving today uh for you PlayStation
dudes I don't even know what a PSP goes
let's just say Andrew it's just keep
your eye on social media this week just
yeah you know just look out for the Lord
look out for the Lords this week
all right let's see I don't even know
what's happening
let's keep it keep it keep an eye out
keep an eye out look man show me the
show again salute everybody came up in
the room appreciate the support
appreciate this did we I think one or
two more before we roll out I came
through just want to make sure that we
got everything yeah okay so we got we
got him Solo in the building two dollar
Super Chat hope everyone is having a
great day happy Sunday yes
cool and then we have let me see
anything else that was it it was not
cool look everybody enjoy your Sunday an
absolute pleasure to have y'all in the
room again the legendary Gene Park rock
with us we will see you next Sunday we
got more fun things praying everybody
enjoy it we got it
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign